welcome to the dazzling world of
artificial intelligence and machine
learning in this thrilling Journey we
will unlock the secrets of machines that
think learn and adapt reshaping our
futures in ways we could only dream of
Imagine computers deciphering human
language cars that drive themselves and
medical Miracles through data driven
diagnosis
it's not Science Fiction it's the power
of AIML join us in this eiml full course
that will help you to step into this
amazing field in next 5 hours we are
going to see AI roadmap how to become an
AI engineer and best AI certifications
machine learning is important to learn
AI so we will help you with the basics
of machine learning Concepts and
algorithms by the end of this video we
will cover the best implementation of AI
that is chat GPD first in your seat
belts because the future is here and
it's driven by the incredible forces of
AI and ML on that note enhance your
professional prospects through
enrollment in postgraduate program in Ai
and machine learning from Simply learn
offered in partnership with both Purdue
University and IBM acquire sought after
competencies encompassing machine
learning deep learning natural language
processing computer vision reinforcement
learning generator if AI prompt
engineering chat GPT and married of
other cutting-edge topics one year of
experience is preferred to enroll in
this course hurry up and enroll Now find
the course Link in the description box
so without any further delay let's begin
so an AI professional is an expert in
the field of artificial intelligence
possessing the Knowledge and Skills to
design develop and Implement AI
Solutions
they play a crucial role in various
Industries leveraging AI Technologies to
solve complex problems and enhance
decision making process they are in high
demand due to the increasing use of AI
in Industries like healthcare finance
and technology and now we will explore
the various career paths for an AI
professional starting with AI research
scientist then we are machine learning
engineer data scientist and LP engineer
computer vision engineer AI ethics and
bias analyst AI product manager AI
software developer so these are the
career paths for an AI professional now
we'll move to the roles and
responsibilities for each profession so
starting with AI research scientist
so the roles and responsibilities are
conduct research to advance Ai and
machine learning Technologies then we
have developed and Implement novel
algorithms and models and another work
is integrate AI into products and
services and then publish research
findings in conferences and journals
then stay updated with the latest
developments in AI research so these are
the roles and responsibilities for AI
research scientists now moving on to the
next role that was machine learning
engineer and now we'll see its roles and
responsibilities that is design and
build machine learning models and
systems collect and pre-process data for
model training tune and optimize
algorithms for performance deploy models
into production environments and monitor
and maintain machine learning systems
and now moving on to the next store that
is data scientist data scientist rules
and responsibilities are as follows
they analyze large data set to extract
meaningful insights they develop
predictive models and data-driven
solutions and they create data
visualizations and reports for decision
making they collaborate with business
teams to identify data driven
opportunities they also ensure that data
privacy and security compliance keep in
handy and now moving on to the next
store that is natural language
processing engineer and LP engineer and
their alternate responsibilities are
they develop NLP models for language
understanding and generation they
pre-process and clean Text data for NLP
task they work on sentiment analysis
chat boards and language translation
they collaborate with linguist and
domain experts for specialized NLP
projects they stay current with NLP
research and Technologies
and now moving on to the next road that
is computer vision engineer
so the computer vision engineer will
compute a vision algorithms for image
and video analysis they develop object
detection image recognition and facial
recognition systems they collaborate
with Hardware teams for embedded Vision
applications they Implement image and
video processing techniques they also
stay updated on computer vision
advancements so these were the roles and
responsibilities for computer vision
engineer now moving on to the next role
that is AI ethics and bias analyst
so starting with their roles and
responsibilities the first one is assess
and mitigate ethical concerns and biases
in AI systems develop and Implement
fairness and bias detection algorithms
ensure AI systems that comply with
ethical guidelines and regulations they
educate teams on ethical AI practices
and they conduct Audits and assessments
of AI models now moving on to the next
role that is AI product manager now
moving on to the next road that is AI
product manager and now we'll see their
roles and responsibilities so they
Define the AI product strategy and
roadmap they collaborate with
stakeholders to gather requirements and
they prioritize features and
functionalities for AI products they
also manage the development and
deployment for AI solutions they also
monitor product performance and gather
user feedback
so these are the steps you need to
follow to become an AI professional so
the step one is mastering the
fundamentals then we have introduction
to machine learning then the third step
is delving deeper into deep learning
then we have practical experience with
data then introduction to natural
language processing and then we have
immersion in computer vision and then
introduction to reinforcement learning
and then engage in Practical projects
and continuous learning so starting with
the step one so what should you do to be
a AI professional so the first step is
mastering the fundamentals so begin your
AI journey by establishing a strong
foundation and Core Concepts get
acquired with essential mathematical
principles such as algebra calculus and
probability additionally take the time
to become proficient in a beginner
friendly programming language like
python which is widely utilized in the
field of AI explore various online
tutorials and education resources to
grasp the fundamental aspects of Python
Programming now moving to step two that
is Introduction to machine learning so
machine learning constitutes a pivotal
component of AI start by comprehending
the concepts of supervised and
unsupervised learning supervised
learning involves the training of models
using label data while unsupervised
learning revolves around the
identification of patterns within
unlabeled data familiarize yourself with
popular machine learning algorithms like
linear regression and decision trees
prioritize gaining an intuitive
understanding of these algorithms before
delving into their mathematical
intricacies and now moving on to the
step 3 that is delving deeper into deep
learning deep learning has witnessed
significant Acclaim in recent years
comments your deep Learning Journey by
acquiring knowledge about neural
networks the fundamental building blocks
of deep learning gain insight into the
structure of neural networks the data
learning mechanisms and their predictive
capabilities explore crucial Concepts
like activation functions back
propagation and gradient descent so this
was about the step three now we'll move
to the step form that is practical
experience with data so data is the
lifeblood of AI applications learn how
to efficiently manipulate and
pre-process data discover techniques for
data cleaning addressing missing values
and transforming data into format
suitable for model training put your
skills into practice by working with
libraries like pandas and numpy which
simplify data manipulation tasks now
moving on to the step 5 that is
Introduction to natural language
processing natural language processing
is focused on enabling machines to
comprehend human language begin by
building a foundation in essential NLP
Concepts such as tokenization the
division of text into words or sentences
stemming reducing words to their root
forms and part of speech tagging
identifying grammatical elements gain
practical experience by experimenting
with NLP libraries like nltk now moving
on to the step 6 that is immersion in
computer vision so computer vision
involves the teaching of machines to
interpret visual information Begin by
exploring image image processing
techniques including filtering and
feature extraction learn about widely
used computer vision algorithms such as
object detection and image
classification repeat put your knowledge
into action by experimenting with
libraries like opencv and tensorflow to
implement computer vision applications
now moving on to the step 7 that is
Introduction to reinforcement learning
reinforcement learning centers on
training agents to make decisions
through process of trial and error start
by understanding Core Concepts such as
rewards States and actions familiarize
yourself with popular algorithms like Q
learning and engage with the
environments like open AI gym to
practice reinforcement learning
then we have the step 8 engaging in
Practical projects and continuous
learning apply your newfound knowledge
through Hands-On projects begin with
small scale projects and progressively
take on more complex challenges
participate in AI communities and
contribute to online forums to
collaborate with fellow Learners and
gain insights from experienced
practitioners stay updated with the
latest developments in AI by following
AI blogs attending webinars and
exploring AI related news sources so in
conclusion I want to say that commencing
your AI Journey as a novice may appear
daunting but by following this
structured roadmap you can progress
systematically and establish a solid
foundation in AI Concepts remember to
prioritize a deep understanding of the
fundamentals engage in Hands-On learning
with real world data and undertake
projects to reinforce your knowledge
Embrace continuous learning and leverage
online resources and communities to
enhance your AI skills
now moving on to the company's hiring AI
professional so Amazon capgemini Oracle
PCS Accenture sap IBM cognizant so these
are the companies and these are the
topmost companies that hire AI
professionals
and now moving on to the average salary
for AI professionals
so nus a beginner AI professional can
earn up to 82 000 to 128 000 and an
experienced professional can earn from
ninety nine thousand dollars to two
hundred thousand dollars and if you talk
about India a beginner can earn from
five lakhs to 12 lakhs per annum and if
you talk about the experience
professional they can earn from 7 lakhs
to 20 lakhs per annum so these data are
just the stats from the glass door and
they can very own the different states
and the countries
so well there you have it folks and
before ending I want to take a minute to
hear from our Learners who have
experienced massive success in their
careers by opting out the boot camp and
the postgraduate program in Ai and
machine learning AI has transformed the
way we live work and interact with
from virtual
AI is revolutionizing every industry
promising groundbreaking advancements
and unimaginable possibilities
but why should you consider a career in
artificial intelligence AI is not just a
passing friend it's a seismic shift that
is reshaping our world and creating new
avenues for Innovation and Discovery by
embracing a career in artificial
intelligence you become a part of a
dynamic field that thrives on solving
complex problems pushing boundaries and
making a profound impact on society the
demand for AI professionals is
skyrocketing across industries from
Healthcare and finance to entertainment
and transportation organizations are
actively seeking talented individuals
who can hardness the power of artificial
intelligence to drive their businesses
forward but what does it take to become
an AI engineer how can you embark on
this thrilling Journal don't worry we
have the answers to all your questions
hello everyone and welcome to Simply do
in this video we'll take you through the
roadmap of how to become an AI engineer
but before we begin if you enjoy
watching these videos and find them
interesting then subscribe to our
YouTube channel because we bring the
best videos for you Dean also press the
Bell icon to never miss any updates from
Simply love some steps are crucial to
master the feel of AI and becoming an AI
engineer so let's go through them real
quick first establish a strong
foundation in mathematics and
programming start by gaining a solid
understanding of critical mathematical
Concepts such as linear algebra calculus
and probability additionally it is
crucial to become proficient in a
programming language like python which
is commonly used in Ai and develop your
coding skills
next pursue a degree in relevant field
earn a bachelor's or master's degree in
computer science data science AI or a
related discipline to acquire a
comprehensive understanding of AI
principles and techniques then acquire
knowledge in machine learning and deep
learning familiarize yourself with male
algorithms neural networks and deep
learning Frameworks like tensorflow and
pytorch to train and optimize models
using real world data sets afterward
engage in Practical projects gain
hands-on experience and demonstrate your
skills by working on AI projects
building a portfolio of projects that
showcase your ability to solve AI
problems can make a strong impression on
potential employers
collaborate and network engage with AI
communities attend conferences and
participate in online forums to connect
with Professionals in the field
collaborating with others can enhance
your learning experience and open up new
opportunities
the next part is seek internships or
entry level positions gain practical
experience through AI internships or
entry-level roles in industry or
research institutions this will provide
valuable exposure and help you further
develop your skills continuously learn
and adapt in the fast-paced world of AI
it is crucial to stay updated on new
developments explore specialized areas
and embrace emerging Technologies and
tools continue learning and adaptability
are essential for pursuing a successful
career as an AI engineer
now that you are familiar with the steps
involved in the Journey of an AI
engineer let's have a look at the salary
of an AI engineer
according to glassdo the average
reported salary of an AI engineer in the
United States is around 105 000 per year
however in India it is around 9 lakh 33
000 rupees per annum these figures are
way better than the average salary of
any job rule let's move forward and
discuss the essential skills you need to
become an AI engineer these skills
include strong programming abilities
knowledge of machine learning algorithms
Proficiency in statistics and
Mathematics familiarity with deep
learning Frameworks and experience with
big data Technologies
excellent problem solving and analytical
skills are also crucial as an AI or
machine learning engineer you need to
perform certain tasks such as developing
testing and deploying AI models through
programming algorithms like random
Forest logistic regression linear
regression and so on the responsibility
of an AI engineer includes convert
machine learning models into application
program interfaces so that other
applications can use it build AI models
from scratch and help the different
components of the organization such as
product managers and stakeholders
understand what results they gain from
the model
build data ingestion and data
transformation infrastructure automate
the infrastructure that the data science
team uses perform statistical analysis
and tune the results so that the
organization can make better informed
decisions
set up and manage AI development and
product infrastructure be a good team
player as coordinating with others is
must artificial intelligence AI has
emerged as a transformative technology
that is revolutioning various aspects of
our lives with its ability to simulate
human intelligence and perform complex
tasks AI has found application in the
field ranging from Healthcare Finance to
transportation and entertainment and
many other fields so let me share you
some fascinating stats with you that
illustrate the impact of the potential
of this game changing technology before
we delve into the fascinating world of
artificial intelligence so according to
Glassdoor the average salary of AI
engineer is one hundred sixty thousand
dollars in United States and in India
it's up to 11 lakh per annum in India
so learning AI offers numerous benefits
ranging from career opportunities and
Innovation to personal growth and
ethical consideration it equips you with
valuable skills and knowledge that can
have profound impact on various aspects
of society and the World At Large but
before choosing the right course to
excel in the field of AI can be
challenging so with so many options
available out there in the market how do
you know which one is the right for you
well we are here to help you without any
further Ado let's discuss the top EI
certification for 2024. number one on
the list is post Gadget program in Ai
and machine learning this postgraduate
program in Ai and machine learning in
collaboration with Purdue University and
IBM offered you by simply learn is an
online program designed you to provide
students with a comprehensive
understanding of AI and machine learning
Concepts tools and techniques these
programs cover various topics such as
data science stat deep learning computer
vision and NLP natural language
processing and help you gain the right
skills on a various tools such as Keras
matplotlib tensorflow Django and many
more furthermore the curriculum is
structured around interactive online
class live session with industry expert
and Hands-On projects the program also
includes access to simple as learning
management system which provide a
student with additional resources such
as practice exercise quizzes and
simulation overall the Purdue
postgraduate program in Ai and machine
learning offered by simply learn is a
well-structured and comprehensive
program that can help a student gain
expertise in Ai and machine learning
Concepts and enhance their careers
Prospect in the field upon completing
the program student will receive a
postgraduate certificate from Purdy
University and IBM indicating that they
have acquired the skills and knowledge
necessary to apply Ai and machine
learning Concept in the real world
situation admission to this post Gadget
program in AIML course requires two plus
years of experience preferred bachelor
degree with an average of 50 percent or
higher mark basic understanding of
programming concept and Mathematics so
hurry up enroll now in the Purdue
postgraduate program in AIML and create
your own successful career the course
link is in the description box below
number two number two on the list is IIT
kanpur professional certificate course
in Ai and machine learning accelerate
your career in Ai and ml without
comprehensive professional certificate
course in Ai and machine learning in
collaboration with IIT kanpur this
machine learning course will equip with
highly coveted skill in ml deep learning
NLP generative AI prompt engineering
chair gbt and much more through live
classes by industry expert master
classes from IIT khanbo faculty and
Hands-On projects you will stay ahead in
the field of AI this AI ml course covers
Concepts like machine learning deep
learning natural language processing
reinforcement learning computer vision
speech recognition generative ai
explainable ai prompt engineering chat
Jeopardy and much more this is date of
art of machine learning course covers
modules that can help you Kickstart a
thriving career in AIML you will also
receive the opportunity to delve into
Cutting Edge AI topics such as
generative AI chatgpt GPT models and
explainable I for admission to this
artificial intelligence course candidate
should have a bachelor degree with an
average of 50 or higher marks preferably
two plus years of experience
prior knowledge or experience in
programming and Mathematics so why bet
enroll now and unlock exciting AIML
opportunities so why wait join our seats
are feeling fast the course link is in
the description box below number third
on the list is AIML bootcamp by Caltech
this AIML bootcamp program May develop
your career as an expert in artificial
Intel and machine learning bootcamp in
the collaboration with Caltech
University the AIML bootcamp offers
master classes by Celtic professors live
classes taught by industry expert
interactive labs and projects relevant
to this industry this bootcamp offers
Caltech academic Excellence simply runs
career resistance campus immersion and
hands-on experience this AIML bootcamp
will help you get noticed but top hiring
companies and helps you in the industry
relevant Capstone project the AIML
bootcamp at Caltech is the best option
for anyone wishing to get a Competitive
Edge in the era of Cutting Edge
Technologies this bootcamp offers
complete understanding of AI based
Technologies like machine learning
natural language processing deep
learning speech recognition
reinforcement learning and much more
this course covers tools and techniques
like python tensorflow Keras matplotlib
and manimo along with industry projects
like social media and e-commerce
manufacturing attack Healthcare and many
more Amazing projects choosing the boot
camp can get you hired by the renowned
companies like Microsoft Google IBM
Amazon Samsung and Adobe this bootcamp
has benefited many aspiring AIML
engineers and professionals candidate
applying for AIML bootcamp should have
the following this boot camp is for the
United States only
be at least 18 years old and have a high
school diploma or equivalent have prior
knowledge or experience in programming
and Mathematics preferably two plus
years of formal work experience so hurry
up and roll now in the AI and ml boot
camp and create your own successful
career the course link is in the
description box below finally we have
Masters in artificial intelligence
program this master program in
artificial intelligence is one of the
most sought after courses offered by
simpler this artificial intelligence
sponsor program in collaboration with
IBM introduces a student to Blended
learning and prepares them to be a
specialist in Ai and data science this
program will teach you the necessary
skills you need to become an AI expert
and land in your dream job this course
covers the basic fundamental of Python
programming languages and its popular
averages like numpy and pandas from
scratch to some Advanced topic like
machine learning algorithm deep learning
natural language processing computer
vision and AI deployment by covering
some important tools like Keras
tensorflow PSI by and many more so what
else you can expect from this program
well this course also includes three
Capstone and 12 industry relevant
projects from the likes of Amazon
Walmart Mercedes-Benz Uber and many more
immersive learning experience it takes
higher in life interaction in the live
AI online classes delivered by seasoned
trainers and Industry expert and simply
learn job assist programs sound
interesting right so what are you
waiting for don't miss out on this
chance to take career to the next level
and role in our artificial intelligence
master program course today and start
your journey to become AI expert the
link is added in the description box
below and the comment section moving
forward let's see the future of AI the
future of AI whole tremendous promising
and potential as technology advances AI
is expected to become more sophisticated
and capable some key trends that will
shape the future of AI include ethical
AI emphasis on fear transparent and
unbiased AI system grows with efforts of
address privacy accountability and
biases ethical concerns Drive regulation
and responsible AI development AI in
robotics integrating with AI robotics
create intelligent robots for complex
tasks in manufacturing Logistics and
Healthcare
a i in iot a I combined with iot and a
versus smart home cities and industries
enhancing decision making and automation
through interconnected devices AI in
personalization AI enhanced personalized
experience in entertainment e-commerce
and marketing by understanding user
preferences and delivering tailored
recommendations the fifth one is
autonomous system self-driving cars
drones and Robotics Advance relying on
AI algorithms and sensor transforming
Transportation logistic and other
industry rather than replacing humans AI
is expected to augment it human
capabilities and enable more effective
collaboration AI system can assist in
decision making automated repetitive
task and provide personalized
recommendations allowing humans to focus
on higher level tasks that require
creativity and critical thinking now
let's look into the types of machine
learning
machine learning is primarily of three
types first one is supervised machine
learning as the name suggests you have
to supervise your machine learning while
you train it to work on its own it
requires label training data next up is
unsupervised learning wherein there will
be training data but it won't be labeled
finally there's reinforcement learning
wherein the system learns on its own
let's talk about all these types in
detail let's try to understand how
supervised Learning Works look at the
pictures very very carefully the monitor
depicts the model or the system that we
are going to train
this is how the training is done we
provide a data set that contains
pictures of a kind of a fruit say an
apple
then we provide another data set which
lets the model know that these pictures
where that of a fruit called Apple
this ends the training phase now what we
will do is we provide a new set of data
which only contains pictures of Apple
now here comes the fun part the system
can actually tell you what fruit it is
and it will remember this and apply this
knowledge in future as well
that's how supervised Learning Works you
are training the model to do a certain
kind of an operation on its own
this kind of a model is generally used
into filtering spam mails from your
email accounts as well yes surprise
aren't you
so let's move on to unsupervised
learning now let's say we have a data
set which is cluttered in this case we
have a collection of pictures of
different fruits we feed this data to
the model and the model analyzes the
data to figure out patterns in it in the
end it categorizes the photos into three
types as you can see in the image based
on their similarities
so you provide the data to the system
and let the system do the rest of the
work simple isn't it
this kind of a model is used by Flipkart
to figure out the products that are well
suited for you
honestly speaking this is my favorite
type of machine learning out of all the
three and this type has been widely
shown in most of the Sci-Fi movies
lately let's find out how it works
imagine a newborn baby you put a burning
candle in front of the baby the baby
does not know that if it touches the
flame its fingers might get burnt
so it does that anyway and gets hurt
the next time you put that candle in
front of the baby it will remember what
happened the last time and would not
repeat what it did that's exactly how
reinforcement learning works
we provide the machine with a data set
wherein we ask it to identify a
particular kind of a fruit in this case
an apple
so what it does as a response it tells
us that it's a mango but as we all know
it's a completely wrong answer so as a
feedback we tell the system that it's
wrong it's not a mango it's an apple
what it does it learns from the feedback
and keeps that in mind
when the next time when we ask a same
question it gives us the right answer it
is able to tell us that it's actually an
apple that is a reinforced response so
that's how reinforcement learning works
it learns from his mistakes and
experiences this model is used in games
like Prince of Persia or Assassin's
Creed or FIFA wherein the level of
difficulty increases as you get better
with the games
just to make it more clear for you let's
look at a comparison between supervised
and unsupervised learning firstly the
data involved in case of supervised
learning is labeled as we mentioned in
the examples previously
we provide the system with a photo of an
apple and let the system know that this
is actually an apple
that is called label data so the system
learns from the label data and makes
future predictions
now unsupervised learning does not
require any kind of label data because
its work is to look for patterns in the
input data and organize it
the next point is that you get a
feedback in case of supervised learning
that is once you get the output the
system tends to remember that and uses
it for the next operation
that does not happen for unsupervised
learning and the last point is that
supervised learning is mostly used to
predict data whereas unsupervised
learning is used to find out hidden
patterns or structures in data
I think this would have made a lot of
things clear for you regarding
supervised and unsupervised learning
chain learning is the art of making
computers learn and act like humans by
creating data and which focuses on
utilization of information and imitating
the way that people learn step by step
working on its accuracy
machine learning is playing a major role
in our day-to-day life machine learning
is used in Trends and pattern
identification automation weather
forecasting and many more machine
learning is classified into supervised
machine learning unsupervised machine
learning reinforcement learning
semi-supervised learning
let's understand supervised machine
learning in detail
provides machine learning machines are
trained using label data also known as
training data to predict the results
here label data refers to a group of
data that have been tagged with one or
more names and data is already known to
the machine
in the real world supervised machine
learning can be used for image and
object recognition Predictive Analytics
customer sentiment analysis spam
detection and many more after
understanding what supervised machine
learning is let's move forward and see
how supervised machine Learning Works
suppose we have a data set that includes
dogs and cats now the first step is that
we need to train the model for each dogs
and cats as per the factors like
similarity pattern shapes and contrast
now after training we test our model
using new data set which is unknown to
the model and the task of the model is
to identify the new input data the
machine is already trained on all types
of similarity patterns shapes and
contrast
when it finds new data it classifies it
on the basis of simulatory patterns
shapes and contracts and predict the
output
as of now we are well aware of how
supervised machine Learning Works let's
have a walkthrough of the advantages and
disadvantages of supervised machine
learning
before diving deep into any technology
it is very important to understand its
advantages and disadvantages here are
some advantages of supervised machine
learning first one is real world
computation problems help you to solve
various types of real world completion
problems like spam detection image and
object recognition and many more the
second one is optimization using past
experience supervised machine learning
can optimize performance criteria
the third one is prediction
in supervised machine learning models
can predict the output based on the past
experience as well fourth one is
reusable data we can reuse the training
data unless there is any future change
supervised machine learning has
advantages as well as disadvantages
let's have a look at some disadvantages
now
computation time is also known as
running time it's very vast for the
supervised machine learning so while
machine learning models always need
updates
reprocessing of data a big challenge for
predicting the output anyone can overlap
supervised machine learning easily it
occurs when a statical model is exactly
against its training data now that we
have an understanding of advantage and
disadvantages let's move forward and
discuss different types of supervised
machine learning
supervised machine learning can be
further classified into two problems
which are classification integration
let's see them one by one in detail
classification is a process of in which
new observation are recognized and
separated in such a way that they can be
categorized assuming you have a group of
things for example vegetables you can
categorize them based on their property
that they have like you can arrange the
potatoes in class A tomatoes in class B
capsicum in class C
these are some popular classification
algorithms that come under supervised
machine learning first one is random
Forest second decision trees third one
is logistic regression fourth one is
support Vector machines
moving forward let's have a look on
regression
a regression algorithm is used to figure
out the connection between a dependent
and independent variables dependent
variables are nothing but a variables
which we are trying to predict or
forecast
and independent variables means that
factors that influence the analysis it
is usually used to make projection for
example we have variable one as humidity
and they are equal to West temperature
where humidity will play the role of
dependent variable and in temperature
will be the independent variable
humidity and temperatures are correlated
in such a way that as temperature
increases humidity will decrease and
vice versa many organization utilize
regression models to predict how stocks
will act from here on this is done by
breaking down the past information on
stock cost and Trends to recognize
pattern these are some popular
regression algorithms that comes under
supervised machine learning first one is
linear regression second one is
digression trees third one is non-linear
regression fourth one is patient linear
regression after discussing the
advantages and disadvantages of
supervised machine learning and its
types let's move forward to see
algorithms in supervised machine
learning
in computer programming terms an
algorithm is a set of well-defined
instruction to solve a particular
problem it takes a bunch of information
sources and delivers the ideal result
the first supervised machine learning
algorithm is linear regression linear
regression is utilized to recognize the
connection between dependent variable
and at least one independent variable
and is commonly utilized to make
forecasts about future results company
frequently use linear regression models
to predict future sales this can be
useful for things like planning and
arranging algorithms like Amazon product
to product collaborative filtering are
utilized to predict what clients will
purchase later on given their past
purchase history
a regression tree is worked through a
cycle known as binary recursive
partitioning which is an alternative
interaction that divides the information
into segments of branches and afterwards
keep splitting each data into smaller
groups as the technique claims each
branch these trees are used for
dependent variables with continuous
value for example a regression tree name
food which divides into segments wedge
and non-wed further it keeps splitting
into smaller groups
non-linear regression is a type of
regression examination wherein
information is fit to model and
afterward communicated as a numerical
function simple linear regression
relates two factors with a straight line
while non-linear regression relates to
two factors in a non-linear relationship
non-linear regression can be used to
predict population growth over time or
the relationship between GDP and the
time of a country
this algorithm is a way to deal with
linear regression in which this statical
examination is attempted inside the
settings of Bayesian inference linear
equation and patient regression can
generate the same prediction and with
the help of patient processing we can
retrieve the complete variety of
inferential solution instead of Quant
estimate
random Forest is one of the most
adaptable supervised machine learning
algorithm utilized for both
classification and regression purposes
random Forest is involved at work by
researchers in numerous Ventures
including banking stock exchanging
mitigation it is utilized to predict the
things which assist these businesses
with running productively like client
activity patient history and safety
a decision tree is a very specific sort
of tree that empowers you to conclude
some kind of process used for dependent
variables predificate values for example
you want to pick between manufacturing
product a on product b or putting
resources into Decision One decision two
or decision three decision trees are an
outstanding method for managing these
kinds of complex choices
Logistics regression is calculated
logically and chosen Bank dependent
variable is category meaning they have
double results for example logistic
regression can be used to whether a
political nominee will win or lose a
political race or regardless of whether
a secondary school student will be
admitted up to a specific School
a support Vector machine is a well-known
supervised machine learning model it is
utilized for the two information
classification and regression all things
considered it is regularly utilized for
grouping issues like weekend involvement
different Life Care Systems we can
involve in typically happy and sad look
arrangement you can involve in filters
if you make specific looks it would add
the particular filter according to the
expression the scope of articulation
lies between happy and sad after
understanding supervised machine
learning algorithms let's move forward
and cover applications of supervised
machine learning choose from over 300
in-demand skills and get access to 1 000
Plus hours of video content for free
visit skillup by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
to provide machine learning models can
be used to build and Advance several
businesses application including the
following the first one is image and
object recognition supervised machine
learning models can be utilized to find
isolate and assault objects out of
recordings of pictures making them
valuable when applied to different
computer design strategies and imagery
analysis the second one is predictive
analysis a broad use case provides
machine learning models is in making
Predictive Analytics systems to give
profound experience into different
business data of Interest this permits
to expect specific outcomes because of a
given result variable assisting Business
Leaders to justify choices or turn to
sub the association
the third one is customer sentiment
analysis utilizing supervised machine
learning models Association can extract
and arrange significant pieces of data
from huge volumes of information
including context emotion and purpose
with very little human intervention
this can be incredibly valuable while
acquiring a superior understanding of
blind into collaboration and can be
utilized to further develop brand
engagement efforts the fourth one is
Spam detection spam identification is
another application of supervised
machine learning model utilizing
classification calculation companies can
prepare data sets to recognize patterns
or anomalies and new information to sort
out spam and non-spam related data
unsupervised learning is a machine
learning technique used to train the
machine learning algorithm using data
that is either unclassified or unlabeled
and allows the algorithm to act on that
data without guidance unlabeled data is
a designation for pieces of data that
have not been tagged with labels
identified by characteristics Properties
or classifications
so the flow of unsupervised learning
starts with training data that has no
labels and depends on the feature Vector
the machine learning model defines the
predictive model this is tested with an
individual subset of data with its own
feature vector here the predictive model
defines the likelihood or cluster ID or
a better representation of unlabeled
data
let's look at the difference between
unsupervised and supervised learning
supervised learning technique deals with
label data where the output data
patterns are known to the system
unsupervised learning works with
unlabeled data in which the output is
just based on the collection of
perceptions
supervised learning method is less
complex the unsupervised learning method
is more complex supervised learning
conducts offline analysis unsupervised
learning performs real-time analysis
the outcome of the supervised learning
technique is comparatively more accurate
and reliable unsupervised learning
generates moderately acute but reliable
results
while classification and regression are
the types of problems solved under the
supervised learning method
unsupervised learning includes
clustering and associative rule mining
problems
example and application of unsupervised
learning let's understand unsupervised
learning through an example
consider a scenario where a child had no
learning phase and is shown images
without the labels now if the child is
asked to identify if any range is a bird
or an animal he will lack the
information that can help him do so the
best he can do is come up with the
following groups based on common
patterns wings and legs for example this
explains how unsupervised Learning Works
we show a lot of data to our algorithm
and ask it to find patterns in the data
by itself
let's look at the application of
unsupervised learning
unsupervised learning can be used for
anomaly detection as well as clustering
to understand clustering let's look at a
simple real life example a mother asks
her two children to arrange the pieces
of plain blocks the children come up
with two different groups as shown with
different similarities in the blocks
this is clustering each of our children
came up with a different type of
grouping one child grouped them based on
the shape whereas the other grouped them
based on the color there is no right or
wrong way
then how can you pick one set of
clusters over the others
this will depend on the similarity
measure used by the mother in this case
the arrangement of child one is better
than child two if the similarity measure
chosen by the mother was that blocks
should have the same shape however the
arrangement by Child 2 is better if the
similarity measure chosen by the mother
was that blocks should have the same
color therefore defining the similarity
measure is important when performing
clustering there may be different ways
in which data can be arranged in
different groups based on size shape
color texture and other complex features
anomaly detection is a clustering
technique used to identify unusual
patterns that do not conform to expected
Behavior anomaly detection has many
applications in business such as
intrusion detection system Health
monitoring and fraud detection
clustering
the method of grouping similar entities
together is called clustering the goal
of this unsupervised machine learning
method is to seek out similarities
within the data points and to Cluster
similar data points together
need for clustering let's look at the
need for clustering grouping similar
entities together helps to merge the
attributes of different clusters in
other words this gives us insight into
underlying patterns of different groups
there are a lot of applications of
grouping unlabeled data for example in
order to maximize the revenue you can
identify different groups or clusters of
customers and Market to each group in a
different way another example is
grouping books together that belong to
similar topics clustering is needed to
determine the intrinsic grouping in a
set of unlabeled data
organize data into clusters that show
internal structure of the data partition
the data points understand and extract
value from large sets of structured and
unstructured data types of clustering
there are two types of clustering
hierarchical clustering and partitional
clustering hierarchical clustering can
be agglomerative and divisive whereas
partitional clustering can be K means
and fuzzy c means a distinction among
different types of clustering is whether
the set of clusters is nested or
unnested a partitional clustering is
just a division of the set of data
objects into non-overlapping sets or
clusters such that every data object is
in just one subset a hierarchical
clustering is a tree structure that has
a set of nested clusters
hierarchical clustering the output of
hierarchical clustering is a hierarchy
how does they hire archical clustering
form a hierarchy assume you are going to
create a three-layer hierarchy from six
different data nodes so first combine a
and based on similarity and also combine
d and e based on similarity combination
of A and B is combined with C in the
similar way combination of d and e is
combined with f now combine C and F
inside one cluster when you look at the
final tree it contains all clusters
combined into a single cluster
let's understand the working of
hierarchical clustering it works in four
steps step one assign each item to its
own cluster such that if you have n
number of items you will have n number
of clusters
Step 2 merge two clusters into a single
cluster by finding the closest pair of
clusters now you will have one cluster
less step three compute distances
between the new cluster and all old
clusters step 4 repeat steps two and
three until all items are clustered into
a single cluster of size n
let's understand the distance measure in
hierarchical clustering let's look at
the different kinds of linkage in
clustering complete linkage clustering
it finds the maximum distance between
points belonging to two different
clusters
single linkage clustering it finds the
minimum possible distance between points
belonging to two different clusters mean
linkage clustering it finds all possible
pairwise distances for points belonging
to two different clusters and then
calculates the average
centroid linkage clustering it finds the
centroid of each cluster and calculates
the distance between them
what is dendrogram
it is a tree diagram frequently used to
illustrate the arrangement of the
Clusters produced by hierarchical
clustering it shows the hierarchical
relationship between objects it is most
commonly created as an output of
hierarchical clustering the main use of
a dendrogram is to work out the best way
to allocate objects to clusters the
dendrogram also shows the hierarchical
clustering of five observations and the
relationship between each of them
hierarchical clustering sample
let's understand hierarchical clustering
through an example in the given example
hierarchical clustering is used to find
the distances between the different
cities in kilometers
the following Matrix traces a
hierarchical clustering of distances in
miles between different cities the
method of clustering is single link here
as you can see from the given distance
Matrix the nearest pair of objects is t
o and MI
Mi and t0 are merged into a single
cluster called Mito as Mi column has
lower values than to column Mito
consists of Mi column values
Mito column has one index with zero
value this is because there is no
distance between cluster Mito and Mito
to get a new distance Matrix we compute
the distance from this new cluster to
all other clusters
now the nearest pair of objects is n a
and RM these are combined into a single
cluster called narm to get a new
distance Matrix we compute the distance
from this new cluster to all other
clusters in the similar way the nearest
pair of objects is ba and narm these are
combined into a single cluster called ba
n a r m to get a new distance Matrix we
compute the distance from the new
cluster to all other clusters
similarly now the nearest pair of
objects is ba narm and f i these
combined into a single cluster called b
a n a rmfi
to get a new distance Matrix we compute
the distance from this new cluster to
all other clusters
finally we merge the last two clusters
this process is summarized by the
clustering diagram on the right and the
final distance Matrix on the left on
that note enhance your professional
prospects through enrollment and
postgraduate program in Ai and machine
learning from Simply learn offered in
partnership with both Purdue University
and IBM acquire sought after
competencies encompassing machine
learning deep learning natural language
processing computer vision reinforcement
learning generative AI prompt
engineering chat GPT and married of
other cutting-edge topics one year of
experience is preferred to enroll in
this course hurry up and enroll Now find
the course Link in the description box
why reinforcement learning training a
machine learning model requires a lot of
data which might not always be available
to us further the data provided might
not be reliable learning from a small
subset of actions will not help expand
the vast realm of solutions that may
work for a particular problem
you can see here we have the robot
learning to walk
very complicated setup when you're
learning how to walk and you'll start
asking questions like if I'm taking one
step forward and left what happens if I
pick up a 50 pound object how does that
change how a robot would walk
these things are very difficult to
program because there's no actual
information on it until it's actually
tried out learning from a small subset
of actions will not help expand the vast
realm of solutions that may work for a
particular problem
and we'll see here it learned how to
walk this is going to slow the growth
that technology is capable of machines
need to learn to perform actions by
themselves and not just learn off humans
and you see the objective climb a
mountain a real interesting point here
is that as human beings we can go into a
very unknown environment and we can
adjust for it and kind of explore and
play with it
most of the models the non-reinforcement
models in computer machine learning
aren't able to do that very well there's
a couple of them that can be used or
integrated to see how it goes is what
we're talking about with reinforcement
learning so what is reinforcement
learning
reinforcement learning is a sub-branch
of machine learning that trains a model
to return an Optimum solution for a
problem by taking a sequence of
decisions by itself
consider a robot learning to go from one
place to another
the robot is given a scenario must
arrive at a solution by itself the robot
can take different paths to reach the
destination
it will know the best path by the time
taken on each path it might even come up
with a unique solution all by itself
and that's really important as we're
looking for Unique Solutions we want the
best solution but you can't find it
unless you try it so we're looking at
our different
systems or different model we have
supervised versus unsupervised versus
reinforcement learning and with the
supervised learning that is probably the
most controlled environment we have a
lot of different supervised learning
models whether it's linear regression
neural networks there's all kinds of
things in between decision trees the
data provided is labeled data with
output values specified and this is
important because we talk about
supervised learning you already know the
answer for all this information you
already know the picture has a
motorcycle in it so your supervised
learning you already know that the
outcome for tomorrow for you know going
back a week you're looking at stock you
can already have like the graph of what
the next day looks like so you have an
answer for it
and you have labeled data which is used
you have an external supervision and
solves Problems by mapping labeled input
to known output
so very controlled
unsupervised learning and supervised
learning is really interesting because
it's now taking part in many other
models they start with an you can
actually insert an unsupervised learning
model
in almost either supervised or
reinforcement learning as part of the
system which is really cool
data provided is unlabeled data the
outputs are not specified machine makes
its own predictions used to solve
association with clustering problems
unlabeled data is used no supervision
solves Problems by understanding
patterns and discovering output
so you can look at this and you can
think some of these things go with each
other they belong together so it's
looking for what connects in different
ways and there's a lot of different
algorithms that look at this when you
start getting into those there's some
really cool images that come up of what
unsupervised learning is how it can pick
out say the area of a donut one model
will see the area of the donut and the
other one will divide it into three
sections based on its location versus
what's next to it so there's a lot of
stuff that goes in with unsupervised
learning
and then we're looking at reinforcement
learning probably the biggest industry
in today's market in machine learning or
growing Market is very it's very infant
stage as far as how it works and what
it's going to be capable of the machine
learns from its environment using
rewards and errors used to solve reward
based problems no predefined data is
used no supervision follows Trail and
error problem solving approach so again
we have a random at first you start with
a random I try this it works and this is
my reward doesn't work very well maybe
or maybe it doesn't even get you where
you're trying to get it to do and you
get your reward back and then it looks
at that and says well let's try
something else and it starts to play
with these different things finding the
best route
so let's take a look at important terms
in today's reinforcement model
and this has become pretty standardized
over the last few years so these are
really good to know we have the agent
agent is the model that is being trained
via reinforcement learning so this is
your actual entity that has however
you're doing it with using a neural
network or a
cue table or whatever combination
thereof this is the actual agent that
you're using this is the model
and you have your environment uh the
training situation that the model must
optimize to is called its environment
and you can see here I guess we have a
robot who's trying to get a chest full
of gyms or whatever and that's the
output and then you have your action
this is all possible steps that can be
taken by the model and it picks one
action and you can see here that's
picked three different routes to get to
the chest of diamonds and gems
we have a state the current position
condition returned by the model
and you could look at this if you're
playing like a video game this is the
screen you're looking at so when you go
back here the environment is a whole
game board so if you're playing one of
those Mobius games
you might have the whole game board
going on but then you have your current
position where are you on that game
board what's around that what's around
you if you were talking about a robot
the environment might be moving around
the yard where it is in the yard and
what it can see what input it has in
that location that would be the current
position condition returned by the model
and then the reward to help the model
move in the right direction it is
rewarded points are given to it to
appraise some kind of action so yeah you
did good or if I didn't do as good
trying to maximize the reward and have
the best reward possible
and then policy policy determines how an
agent will behave at any time it acts as
a mapping between action and present
State this is part of the model what is
your action that you're you're going to
take what's the policy you're using to
have an output from your agent one of
the reasons they separate policy as its
own entity
is that you usually have a prediction of
a different options and then the policy
well how am I going to pick the best
based on those predictions I'm going to
guess at different options
and we'll actually weigh those options
in and find the best option we think
will work so it's a little tricky but
the policy thing is actually pretty cool
how it works let's go ahead and take a
look at a reinforcement learning example
and just in looking at this we're going
to take a look consider what a dog that
we want to train so the dog would be
like the agent so you have your your
puppy or whatever and then your
environment is going to be the whole
house or whatever it is or where you're
training them and then you have an
action we want to teach the dog to fetch
so action equals fasting
uh and then we have a little biscuit so
we can get the dog to perform various
actions by offering incentives such as a
dog biscuit as a reward
the dog will follow a policy to maximize
this reward and hence will follow every
command and might even learn new actions
like begging by itself so you have big
you know so we started off with fetching
it goes oh I get a biscuit for that and
try something else you get a handshake
or begging or something like that and it
goes oh this is also reward based and so
it kind of explores things to find out
what will bring it is biscuit
and that's very much like how reinforced
model goes is it looks for different
rewards how do I find can I try
different things and find a reward that
works
the dog also will want to run around and
play an explore its environment this
quality of model is called exploration
so there's a little Randomness going on
in Exploration
and explores new parts of the house
climbing on the sofa doesn't get a
reward in fact it usually gets kicked
off the sofa
so let's talk a little bit about
markov's decision process
is a reinforcement learning policy used
to map a current state to an action
where the agent continuously interacts
with the environment to produce new
Solutions and receive rewards and you'll
see here's all of our different
vocabulary we just went over we have a
reward our state our agent our
environment interaction and so even
though the environment kind of contains
everything
that you really when you're actually
writing the program your environment's
going to put out a reward and state that
goes into the agent
the agent then looks at this state or it
looks at the reward usually um first and
it says okay I got rewarded for whatever
I just did or it didn't get rewarded and
then looks at the state and then it
comes back and if you remember from
policy the policy comes in and then we
have a reward the policy is that part
that's connected at the bottom
and so it looks at that policy and it
says hey what's a good action that will
probably be similar to what I did or
sometimes they're completely random but
what's a good action that's going to
bring me a different reward
so taking the time to just understand
these different pieces as they go
is pretty important in most of the
models today and so a lot of them
actually have templates based on this
you can pull in and start using
pretty straightforward as far as once
you start seeing how it works you can
see your environment sends it says hey
this is what the agent did this if
you're a character in a game this
happened and it shoots out a reward in a
state the agent looks at the reward
looks at the new state and then takes a
little guess and says I'm going to try
this action and then that action goes
back into the environment it affects the
environment the environment then changes
depending on what the action was and
then it has a new state and a new reward
that goes back to the agent so in the
diagram Sean we need to find the
shortest path between node A and D each
path has a reward associated with it and
the path with a maximum reward is what
we want to choose
the node a b c d denote the nodes to
travel from node A to B is an action
reward is the cost of each path and
policy is each path taken
and you can see here a can go to B
or a can go to C right off the bat or it
can go right to D and if you explored
all three of these you would find that a
going to D was a zero reward a going to
C and D would generate a different
reward
or you could go acbd there's a lot of
options here and so when we start
looking at this diagram you start to
realize
that even though today's reinforced
learning models do really good at
finding an answer they end up trying
almost all the different directions you
see
and so they take up a lot of work or a
lot of processing time for reinforcement
learning they're right now in their
infant stage and they're really good at
solving simple problems and we'll take a
look at one of those in just a minute in
a tic-tac-toe game but you can see here
once it's gone through these and it's
explored it's going to find the ACD is
the best reward it gets a full 30 points
for it in computer programming an
algorithm is a set of well-defined
instruction to solve a particular
problem
it takes a bunch of information sources
and deliver the ideal result most of us
must be using a Snapchat to apply
filters on your faces while making
videos or capturing photographs but do
you know how does Snapchat recognize
your face while capturing videos or
photographs and put filters on it even
if there are multiple faces it applies
filter on every face accurately this
became possible with the help of phase
recognition technique which uses machine
learning algorithms to detect phases and
apply required filters on them so this
is the basic idea of how an algorithms
work let's move ahead in this video and
we will now discuss how an algorithm
work in machine learning but before that
let's go through what is machine
learning
machine learning is the subpart of
artificial intelligence the art of
making computers learn and act like
humans by feeding data and make
predictions based on experience as we
saw in previous example when the data
that is how far is the nearest fuel
station comes in the machine or in our
case CD immediately start analyzing data
and machine accurately makes prediction
and decision based on given data now
that we have an understanding of what
machine learning is let's move forward
and discuss different types of machine
learning
machine learning is classified into
supervised learning unsupervised
learning reinforcement learning there
are two sort of problems in supervised
learning classification and regression
certain types of machine learning
algorithms fall under the
classifications are decision algorithm
KNN algorithm logistic algorithms name
base algorithm support Vector machine
algorithm svm however integration types
of machine learning algorithms are
linear regression regression trees
non-linear regression and Bayesian
linear regression
you know talking about unsupervised
learning there are two sorts of problems
in unsupervised learning clustering and
Association algorithms that fall under
clustering problems include k-means
clustering algorithms principal
component analysis algorithms however
algorithms that fall under Association
problem are a priority algorithms FP
growth algorithms and reinforcement
learning there are two types positive
reinforcement negative reinforcement
reinforcement learning algorithms are
mainly used in AI applications and
gaming applications
there are certain types of problems
which force under reinforcement learning
are Q learning State action reward State
action sarsa algorithms if you neural
network and Markov decision process
after discussing what machine learning
is and its side let's move forward to
see how algorithms work in machine
learning
everyone knows the algorithm is a
step-by-step process to approach a
particular problem
there are numerous examples of
algorithms from figuring out sets of
number to finding routes through maps to
showing data on a screen let's
understand this by using an example
every algorithm is built on inputs and
outputs Google search algorithm is no
different the input is the search field
and the output is the page of result
that appears when you enter a particular
phrase or keyword also known as serp or
search engine result page
Google has a search algorithm so it can
sort results from various website and
provides the users the best result
when you start a search you will see the
search box will attempt to guess what
you are looking for in order to better
understand what the user is looking for
the algorithm is trying to gather as
many as suggestions from them as
possible
the results from the search field that
best matches the query will be ranked
the choose fit website will Rank and in
what position using more than 200
ranking variables now let's take an
example of coding program and see how
the algorithm works
here we will use a case of computer
program wherein we want to print the
multiplication table of any number let's
take two the algorithms start here and
then it assign a value to a variable the
variable I is having an initial value of
1. the system will read the number the
number in case is 2. now the system has
a condition a condition can now either
be true or false if the value of I
reaches 11 then the loop will end
otherwise value of I will multiply by
the number
the initial value of I is 1 so for the
first time the system output will be 2.
now value of I will be increased by 1.
according to the loop condition
the system will then move back and check
for the condition again
the new value of I is 2. which is still
less than 11 the system will again print
2 into Y which is 2 into 2 on this
screen
the new output result will be 4. the
system will keep following the same
procedure repeatedly until the value of
I becomes 11. once the value of I
becomes 11 then only the algorithm will
terminate after discussing how an
algorithm work let's move forward and
see some popular machine learning
algorithms
some popular machine learning algorithms
are
first one is linear regression algorithm
second one is logistic regression
algorithm
and the third one is decision tree
and the fourth one is support Vector
machine algorithm svm
and the fifth one is KNN K nearest
neighbor algorithms the sixth one is K
means clustering algorithms the and the
seventh one is random Forest algorithms
and the last but not the least algorithm
is proprietary algorithms let's go
through them in detail one by one
linear depression is one of the most
famous and straightforward machine
learning algorithms utilized for
predictive analysis linear regression
show the linear connection between the
dependent and independent factors
the equation of line is y equals to MX
plus b here y stand for this response
variable or a dependent variable whereas
X is for the Predator variable or an
independent variable it attempts best to
fit line between the dependent and
independent variables and this best bit
line is known as line of regression or
regression line
let's take a real application example in
predicting consumer Behavior businesses
use linear regression to forecast things
like how much a client is likely to
spend
things like targeted marketing and
product development May benefit from
this Walmart for instance use linear
regression to forecast which good would
be in high demand Across the Nation
moving forward let's see types of linear
regression
there are two types of linear regression
algorithm
the first one is simple linear
regression and the second one is
multiple linear regression
in simple linear regression if an
independent variable is utilized to
focus the worth of a mathematical
dependent variable then at that point
such a linear regression algorithm is
called Simple linear regression the
equation of line will be y equals to a0
plus a 1 X
and the second one is multiple linear
regression if the dependent variables
declines on the Y and that if
independent variable on the X
then such a relationship is known as
negative linear relationship the line of
equation will be minus of a0 plus a 1 X
moving forward let's see logistic linear
regression
logistic regression is the supervised
machine learning algorithm utilized to
anticipate all the categorical factors
or discrete values it could be very well
used for the grouping issues in machine
learning and the result of the logistic
regression can be either yes or no 0 or
1 men or women and so on it gives the
values which lies between 0 and 1. for
example a credit card business is
interested in knowing whether the
transaction amount and the credit score
have an impact on the probability that a
particular transaction would be
fraudulent the business can use logistic
reduction to determine how these two
Predator values can relate the
probability that a transaction is
fraudulent this response variable in the
model has two possible outcomes
first one is the transaction is
shortland and the second one is the
transaction is not fraudulent
in logistic regression rather than
fitting a regression line with it an S
form logistic capability which predicts
two greatest value 0 or 1. the logistic
regression equation can be calculated
from linear regression equation the
steps to get logistic regression
equations are the equation of straight
line can be written as y equals to b0
plus B1 X1 plus b 2 x 2 till b n x n in
logistic regression y can be between 0
and 1 only so for that let's divide the
above equation by 1 minus y then the
equation will be y upon 1 minus y that
is 0 for y 0 and Infinity for y equals
to 1 but range between minus infinity to
plus infinity then we have to take the
logarithm of equation and now it will
become log of Y upon 1 minus y equals to
b0 plus B1 X1 plus b 2 x 2 so on till B
and x n let's move forward and see types
of logistic regression
there are three types of logitive
regression that can be classified first
one is binomial in binomial logistic
regression there can be only two
possible types of dependent variables
like yes or no password man woman and
many more and the second one is
multinomial in multinomial logistic
regression there can be three or more
possible unordered ways of dependent
variable such as horse cow and sheep and
the last one is ordinal in ordinal
logistic regression there can be three
or more possible ordered ways of
dependent variable such as small medium
or large moving forward let's see
decision trees in detail
a decision tree is a tree structured
classifier that could be used for
classification and regression a decision
tree is a tree in which each non-leaf
node is assigned to an attribute
additionally each are contained one of
the available values for its parent node
which is associated with each Leaf node
that is the node from where the arc is
directed
let's see some decision tree terminology
first one is root that contains the
entire data set the next one is node a
test for the data of a certain attribute
and the third one is branch which
connects the node to internal node or
the internal node to Leaf node and the
fourth one is leaf node the terminal
node that predicts the outcome let's
move forward and see decision tree
algorithms the first one is select the
best attribute to use the current node
in the tree the second one is for each
possible values select the attributes
the third one is partition the examples
using the possible values of this
attribute and assign these disjoint
subset or the example to the appropriate
child node recursively generate each
child node until ideally all examples
for a node have the same label like
class moving forward let's understand
this recently for building a decision
tree Step One is Select an attribute
then split the data into its children in
a tree continue splitting with available
attributes
and keep splitting until late node are
pure like only one class remains a
maximum depth is released a performance
metric is achieved let's move forward
and see svm algorithm support Vector
machine algorithms
a support Vector machine is a well-known
supervised machine learning model it is
utilized for both information
classification and regression
it is regularly utilized for the
grouping issues we can involve it in
different life care system and we can
involve it in typically happy or sad
look Arrangements we can involve it in
filters if we make specific Loops it
would add the particular filter
according to the expression the scope of
articulation lies between happy and sad
support Vector machine helps them to
recognize and return characters use
widely like checks continue to reach a
significant part of the majority of
non-cash transaction and are frequently
written by the pupil the current check
processing system in many developing
nations involves a bank employee to read
and manually enter the information in a
check while also verifying the data like
signature and date
a handwritten tax recognition system can
reduce expenses and labor hours because
a bank must handle several checks each
day
moving forward let's see the algorithm
of svm
the objective of support Vector machine
is to make the best line or Choice limit
that can isolate and dimensional space
into classes so we can undoubtedly put
the new data of interest in the right
category later on this batch decision
boundary is known as a hyperplate let's
move forward and see types of support
Vector machine support Vector machine
can be of two types first one is linear
svm second one is non-linear SPM let's
move forward and see linear sphere
linear svm is utilized for linearly
detachable information
which implies if a data set can be
ordered into two classes by utilizes a
straight line then such information are
named linearly separable information and
a classifier is utilized called linear
XVM classifier moving forward let's see
non-linear sbm
non-linear SPM is utilized for
non-dietly isolated information and that
implies in the event that a data set
can't be categorized by utilizing a
straight line such information is named
non-directed information
and the classifier utilize is called a
non-linear svm classifier moving forward
let's see k n algorithm in detail
KNN is a supervised learning technique
Canon classifies new data into our
targeted classes depending on the
features of its neighboring points and
also be used for the regression problems
it is an instance based learning
algorithm and a bit lazy learning
algorithm k n calculation stores every
one of its accessible information and
orders another information Point based
on the likeliness this means that when
new data information appears it usually
tends to the successfully categorized
into a good suit classes using the k n
algorithm let's imagine we have an image
of animal that resembles a cow or Ox
however here we are not sure if it is a
cow or Ox as k n method is based on a
likeness Matrix it will identify the
properties of new data that are related
to the image of cow or ox and based on
those quality it will classify the data
is belonging to either cow or Ox group
moving forward let's see how does KNN
work
the steps to implement k n algorithms
are step one decide on the neighbor's K
numbers Step 2 calculate the euclidean
distance between K Neighbors in step 2.
third one is based on the determined
euclidean distance select the K closest
neighbors step 4 is count the numbers of
data points in each category between
these connectors step 5 assign the fresh
data points in the category where the
highest neighbors count and then k n
model is ready
Let's see we need to add a new data
point to the vital category at first we
will decide on the numbers of neighbors
therefore we will pick k equals to 5.
then the euclidean distance between the
data points and then can be determined
the distance between two points known as
the euclidean distance can be determined
by under root of X2 minus X when the
whole square plus Y2 minus y1 whole
Square then we determine the closest
neighbors by calculating the euclide
distance
there are three closest Neighbors in
category a and two closest neighbor in
category B
this new data point Must Fall with
category a because as we can see its
three closest neighbors are also from
group a after understanding k n
algorithm let's move forward and see
k-means algorithms in detail
the K means is the cluster false under
that is announced provides learning
algorithm it is used to address machine
learning clusting problems and utilize
to tackle the grouping issues in machine
learning
it permits us to Bunch the information
into various Gatherings it is a helpful
method for finding the classification of
groups in the unlabeled data set without
the requirement of any training this
k-means algorithm groups the data into
similar classes let's see some
application of k-means clustering let's
see some applications of k-means
clustering diagnostic system the medical
profession uses k-means cursing in
creating smarter medical decision
support system especially in the
treatment of liver alignments the second
one is search engines clustering forms a
backbone of search engine when a search
engine is performed the search result
need to be grouped and the search
engines very open use clustering to do
this moving forward let's see how
k-means algorithm works
his steps to implement k-means
algorithms are step one select the
number key to set the number of clusters
Step 2 select a random K points or
centroid step 3 assign each data point
the closest centroid data forms to
predefined a cluster step 4 determine
the variance and a certain new Gravity
points for each cluster step 5 repeat
the third step this means G allocating
each data point to the new closest
centroid cluster step 6 if I
reassignment occurs go to step 4
otherwise go to exit step 7 the model is
ready to use
so now we have a clear understanding of
how k-means algorithm work let's move
forward to see the graphical
representation of k-means algorithm
consider that there are two variables M1
and M2 this is a scatter plot of these
two variables along the X and Y axis we
should accept the number of K of punches
that is k equals to 2 to recognize the
data set and to place them into various
groups it implies here we will attempt
to Bunch these data set into two unique
groups people really want to pick an
irregular key point or centroid to frame
this group
these centroids can be either the focus
of the data set or some of other points
thus here we are choosing under two
points as capoints which are not the
piece of our data set
we will assign every data of interest in
this scatter plot to the nearest K point
or centroid we will register it by
applying some math that we consider to
find the distance between two points
that is euclidean distance thus we will
draw a median between both the centroids
from the graph the left half of the line
are close points to the right and the K1
centroid green is near the orange
centroid we should variety them as green
and orange for Clear representation as
the need might arise to track down the
nearest group we will repeat the cycle
by picking another centroid
to pick the new centroid we will figure
out the center point of gravity of these
centroid and will track down new
centroids then we will reassign every
piece of information to highlight new
centroid for this we will repeat a
similar course of tracking down a middle
line the middle will be like as seen in
the picture one orange point is on the
left half of the line and two green
points are on the right thus these three
points will be appointed to the new
centroids as reassignment has occurred
we will again go to step 4 tracking down
new centroids or k points we will repeat
the cycle by tracking down the center
point of gravity of centroid so the new
centroids will be displayed as like this
we now have new centroid so once more
defined the middle boundary and reassign
the data of Interest by this graph there
are no unique pieces of information on
one of the other side of the line
implying our model is shaped by the
previous graph there are no unique
pieces of information on one or the
other line
implying our model is shaped as our
k-means model is ready and the two plus
groups will be displayed as like these
now we have a clear understanding of how
k-means clustering algorithm works now
let's move forward to understand random
Forest algorithm
random Forest is an adaptable simple to
utilize machine learning algorithm that
produces even without the hyper boundary
tuning an extraordinary outcome more
often that Norm it is likewise quite
possibly the most utilized algorithm
because of its effortness and variety
like its tend to be utilized for both
grouping and classification tasks
random Forest is a classifier that
contains various Choice trees on
different subsets of the given data set
and takes the normal to work on the
present exactness of the data set
instead of depending on the choice tree
the random Forest takes the forecast
from each tree and in light of the
larger part of boards of expectation it
predicts the final result
now let's move forward and see how does
random Forest work
we should see the random forest in order
since the arrangement is now and again
thought to be the structured block of
machine learning this is what a random
Forest would look like with two trees
the random Forest has a similar hyper
meter 2tr decision tree or a paging
classifier luckily there is a compelling
reason need to consolidate a decision
trade with a paging classifier
since you can undoubtedly utilize the
classifier classes of random forests
with random Forest you can likewise
manage tasks using the algorithm
regression random forests add extra
arbitness to the model while deploying
the trees rather than looking for the
man element while parting a node
it looks to the best component among an
irregular subset of highlights these
outcomes in a wide variety often result
in a superior model
subsequently in a random Forest just a
random subset of the element is thought
about the algorithms you might make
trees more random by involving random
edges for each component instead of
looking for the most ideal limits like a
typical Choice Traders
let's move forward and see some
application of random Forest algorithms
random Forest is involved at work by
researchers in numerous Ventures
including banking stock exchanging
medication and many more it is utilized
to predict things which assist these
businesses with running productively
like client activity patient registry
and safety in banking random Forest is
used to identify clients who are more
likely to pay back their debts on
schedule
additionally it is utilized to forecast
who will make more frequent use of Bank
Services even fraud detection uses it
the robin out of algorithms indeed
random Forest is a tool used by stock
Trader to forecast future stock Behavior
retail businesses utilize it to make
product recommendation and forecast
client satisfaction random forage can be
used in healthcare industry to examine a
patient medical history and detect
disorders random Forest is a tool used
by pharmaceutical expert to determine
the ideal mix of ingredients in
treatment or to forecast drug
sensitivity by seeing application of
random Forest algorithm let's move
forward and see some difference between
decision trees and endoporous
let's see the difference between random
forest and decision tree the first one
is
while building a random Forest the
number of rows is selected randomly
in decision trees it builds several
decision trees and find out the output
the second one is it combines two or
more decision trees together in decision
trees whereas the decision is a
collection of variables or data sets or
attributes the third one is it gives
accurate results whereas it gets less
accurate results the fourth one is by
using random Forest it reduces the
chance of overlifting whereas decision
trees it has the possibility of
overlifting the fifth one is random
Forest is more complicated to
interpreters whereas the decision tree
is simple it is easy to read and
understand
after seeing what is random Forest how
it works let's move forward to see a
primary algorithm in detail
algorithm utilize standard item sets to
create calculation rules and is intended
to chip away the information basis
containing exchanges with the assistance
of these application rules it decide how
firmly perceivedly two objects are
associated
this algorithm utilize a breakfast
search and history to work out the items
at Association effectively
it is the iterative interaction for
finding out the successive item set from
the huge data set
let's move forward and see steps for a
priority algorithms the steps for a
priority algorithms are Step One is
establish minimal support and confidence
for item set in the transactional
database the second one is take all
transaction supports with a greater
support value the minimum or chosen
support value in Step 2 the third one is
track down all the rules in these
subsets with confidence value greater
than the threshold value the fourth one
is arrange the rules to lower the lift
at last we will see some advantages and
disadvantages of a priority algorithm
the advantages of a priority algorithms
are easy to understand an algorithm and
the second one is the join and prune
steps of the algorithms can be easily
implemented on the large data set the
disadvantages of a priority algorithms
are they are priority algorithms work
slowly as compared to the other
algorithm and the second one is the a
priority algorithms times and space
complexity are o of 2D which is very low
compared to the other ones machine
learning has improved our lives in a
number of wonderful ways today let's
talk about some of these I am Rahul from
Simply learn and these are the top 10
applications of machine learning first
let's talk about virtual personal
assistance Google Assistant Alexa
Cortana and Siri now we've all used one
of these at least at some point in our
lives now these help improve our lives
in a great number of ways for example
you could tell them to call someone you
could tell them to play some music you
could tell them to even schedule an
appointment so how do these things
actually work first they record whatever
you're saying send it over to a server
which which is usually in a cloud decode
it with the help of machine learning and
neural networks and then provide you
with an output so if you ever noticed
that these systems don't work very well
without the internet that's because the
server couldn't be contacted next let's
talk about traffic predictions now say I
wanted to travel from Buckingham Palace
to Lord's cricket ground the first thing
I'd probably do is to get on Google Maps
so search it
and let's put it here
so here we have the path you should take
to get to large cricket ground now here
the map is a combination of red yellow
and blue now the blue regions signify a
clear road that is you won't encounter
traffic there the yellow indicate that
they are slightly congested and red
means they are heavily congested so
let's look at the map a different
version of the same map and here as I
told you before red means heavily
congested yellow means slow moving and
blue means clear
so how exactly is Google able to tell
you that the traffic is clear slow
moving or heavily congested so this is
the help of machine learning and with
the help of two important measures first
is the average time that's taken on
specific days at specific times on that
route the second one is the real-time
location data of vehicles from Google
Maps and with the help of sensors some
of the other popular map services are
Bing Maps maps.me and here we go next up
we have social media personalization so
say I want to buy a drone and I'm on
Amazon and I want to buy a DJI mavic Pro
the thing is it's close to one lap so I
don't want to buy it right now but the
next time I'm on Facebook I'll see an
advertisement for the product next time
I'm on YouTube I'll see an advertisement
even on Instagram I'll see an
advertisement so here with the help of
machine learning Google has understood
that I'm interested in this particular
product hence it's targeting me with
these advertisements this is also with
the help of machine learning let's talk
about email spam filtering now this is a
spam that's in my inbox now how does
Gmail know what spam and what's not spam
so Gmail has an entire collection of
emails which have already been labeled
as spam or not spam so after analyzing
this data Gmail is able to find some
characteristics like the word lottery or
winner from then on any new email that
comes to your inbox goes through a few
spam filters to decide whether it's spam
or not now some of the popular spam
filters that Gmail uses is content
filters header filters General Blacklist
filters and so on next we have online
fraud detection now there are several
ways that online fraud can take place
for example there's identity theft where
they steal your identity fake accounts
where these accounts only last for how
long the transaction takes place and
stop existing after that and man in the
middle attacks where they steal your
money while the transaction is taking
place the feed forward neural network
helps determine whether a transaction is
genuine or fraudulent so what happens
with feed forward neural networks are
that the outputs are converted into hash
values and these values become the
inputs for the next round so for every
real transaction that takes place
there's a specific pattern a fraudulent
transaction would stand out because of
the significant changes is that it would
cause with the hash values Stock Market
trading machine learning is used
extensively when it comes to Stock
Market trading now you have stock market
indices like nikai they use long
short-term memory neural networks now
these are used to classify process and
predict data when there are time lags
the one known size and duration now this
is used to predict stock market trends
assist to Medical Technology now medical
technology has been innovated with the
help of machine learning diagnosing
diseases has been easier from which we
can create 3D models that can predict
where exactly there are lesions in the
brain it works just as well for brain
tumors and Ice chemic stock lesions they
can also be used in fetal Imaging and
cardiac analysis now some of the medical
fields that machine learning will help
assist in is disease identification
personalized treatment drug Discovery
clinical research and radiology and
finally we have automatic translation
now say you're in a foreign country and
you see Billboards and science that you
don't understand that's where automatic
translation comes of help now how does
automatic translation actually work the
technology behind it is the same as the
sequence of sequence learning which is
the same thing that's used with chatbots
here the image recognition happens using
convolutional neural networks and the
text is identified using optical
character recognition furthermore the
sequential sequence algorithm is also
used to translate the text from one
language to the other
what is a specific cognition system
a program capacity to convert spoken
language into written language is known
as a speech recognition system also
known as automatic series recognition
computer voice recognition or speech to
text despite being sometimes confused
with voice recognition speech
recognition focus on converting speech
form a verbal to a text format whereas
voice recognition only aims to
distinguish the voice of a certain
person
voice and speech recognition are two
distance Technologies and they shouldn't
be confused
to recognize word in spoken language
speech recognition is used voice
recognition uses biometrical
Technologies to recognize a specific
person by their voice
so after knowing what is speech
recognition system let's move forward
and see how does speech recognition
system work
peace recognition in Python works with
algorithm that performs linguistic and
acoustic modeling acoustic modeling is
used to recognize phonetics in our space
to get the more significant part of
speech as words and sentences specific
cognition start by taking the sound
energy produced by the person speaking
and converting it into the electrical
energy
with the help of microphone it then
converts the electrical energy from
analog to digital and finally to the
text
it breaks the audio data down into
sounds and it analyze the sound using
algorithm to find the most probable word
that fits that audio
all of this is done using natural
language processing NLP and neural
networks
hidden markup models can be used to find
temporal patterns in speech and improve
accuracy so here is one question for you
guys I will give you one minute for this
you can comment or you can give your
answer in the chat section so I can see
if the answer is given by you are right
or wrong
I am repeating again so here is one
question for you guys I will give you
exactly one minute for this you can
comment or you can give answer in the
chat section so I can see if the answer
is given by you are right or wrong
so the question is
which of the following is the correct
extension for the python file
I'm repeating again which of the
following is the correct extension of
the Python file
option a DOT python option b dot PL
option C Dot py and option D dot p
so let us know your answer in the
comment section below
so I'm starting a timer of one minute
just type your answer in the comment
section or in the chat section do let me
know your answers please I kindly ask
that everyone take part in this to make
this live session exciting
so I am starting the timer
you can comment or you can give your
answer in the chat section so I can see
if the answers given by you are right or
wrong so the question is which of the
following is the correct extension of
the Python file
37 seconds remaining
option a DOT python option b dot PL
option C dot py option D dot p
let us know your answer in the comment
section below
I can't ask that everyone take part in
this to make the live session exciting
you have 15 seconds remaining
and seconds more
which of the following is the correct
extension of the Python file
three two one after that allotted time
has passed Those Who provided the
correct or response will receive as
response and those Who provided the
incurrent response will receive one
okay so now let's move to our
programming part to create a speech
recognition system using python so first
we will open a command prompt to write a
command to open jupyter notebook so here
we will write Jupiter
notebook
press enter
so this is the landing page of Jupiter
notebook and here you can select new
python file
so this is how the Jupiter notebook UI
looks like so at first we will import
some major libraries of python which
will help us in creating speech
recognition system
so here we will write
first let me remain rename this
each
record
so first I will import import
teach
underscore
recognition
and second import
s x three
press enter
so the incredibly attention repeat the
incredibly extensible species
recognition Library serves as a wrapper
for a number of well-known speech apis
the speech recognition Library includes
default API key for one of these the
Google web speech API hard coded that
implies that you can start moving
without needing to register for a
service
and python project would benefit greatly
from using the speech recognition
package due to its versatility and
usability
and then pydts X3 a python text to
speech conversion library is called pyts
X3
it is compatible with python 2 and
Python 3 and work offline unlike
competing libraries to obtain a
reference to a pyts X3 engine instance
an application calls the pytts X3 init
it is very user friendly program that
turns tab text to into speech
so moving forward let's write code for
actual speech recognition system
so here I will write
Sr equals to speech
underscore
recognition
Dot
recognizer
R must be Capital here
here I will write with
speech
underscore
recognition
dot microphone
X
sorts
2.
then colon
yeah
here
I will write print
we'll write here okay silence
these
then I will write here Sr dot adjust
underscore for underscore
ambient
underscore noise
then source
2 comma duration
equals to 2.
okay
then enter
then I will print something like
eek
now
please
something like that
then I will write here audio
to
equals to Sr
Dot listen
source
2.
and here I will write for text equals to
Sr
Dot
recognize
yeah
underscore
Google
audio
2.
then here I have to print in small
letters
in lower case so I will write here text
equals to text
dot lower
this
then here I will write print
it you say
Plus
text
everything look great
so a recognizer is a machine ability to
listen to spoken words and identify them
you can then use a speed recognition in
Python to convert the spoken words into
text make a query or a give a reply you
can even program some devices to respond
to these spoken words
like every time the recognized speech
from mic function is invoked the
recognizer is calibrated for changing
noise condition using the edges for
ambient noise this one for ambient noise
the backlog parameter of the listen
function allow a quiz size to be
specified it will listen to what we are
speaking or saying
this recognize Google
a function on the recognizer class
which you have now developed will be
used to query the Google web speech API
and convert spoken words into text
recognize Google needs the argument
audio data in order to function properly
otherwise it will fail
python built-in function lower is mostly
used to handle strings
the lower method converts each Capital
character in The provided string to
lowercase before returning the lower
caste string it accept no arguments it
returned to the original text if the
supplied string has no capital letters
now let's check whether it's working or
not so I will run it yeah
Renault
hello how are you doing
yeah you can see hello how are you doing
printed
so let me try another one
subscribe to Simply learn YouTube
channel and press that Bell icon to
never miss any update from Simply learn
so here you can see subscribe to Simply
on YouTube channel and press that Bell
icon to never miss any update from
Simply learn is printed
so SPH to text is working fine
so I hope you guys understand till here
if you have any questions or any queries
regarding any code or you have any
questions just put us in comments our
team will shortly provide you with the
correct solution
now moving forward what if you want that
system we'll write what we are saying
and speak that too
this will be printed and now moving
forward what if you want the system will
write what we are saying and speak that
too
so for that we will write a small line
of code
so first we will do
we will create one here
like we will insert cell below we will
write a function here so d f
speak now
command
colon then voice equals to
p y t t s x 3
dot init
okay then voice dot say
command
and voice
dot run
and
wait
yeah
so what we will do here
we will write like speak
now
then
so this voice is nothing just a variable
to text to speech an innate p y d t x 3
engine has started obtains a pointer to
an instance of an engine that will
utilize the specified driver
if another engine stand is already using
the given driver the other engine stance
is written if not a new engine is built
a speed now is a function in which using
get function I am getting the values of
the text this one I will get
now let's run this sort of code and
let's see if it is working or not so I
will run
hello how are you all
Peak now is not different okay
speak now okay and is small
okay my bad run this again
hello how are you all
I hope you can hear properly so let me
run this again for another demo example
subscribe to Simply learn YouTube
channel and press that Bell icon to
never miss any update from Simply learn
subscribe to simple and YouTube channel
and press the Bell icon to never miss
any updates from simplerlearn yeah so I
hope you guys understand Taylor if you
have any question or any queries
regarding any code
or you have any question related to
python just put as in comments our team
will shortly provide you with the
correct solution
okay okay moving forward so at last
let's create a speech recognition system
from which we can open our websites and
all like YouTube like Facebook like
simply learn anything so we will open
open new file for this I will create the
separate one
here I will write speech
to web
websites
okay
speech
to web
so here I will import import speech
underscore
recognition
then
import
pyts X3
then one major Library import
web browser
okay then I will run it yeah
I hope you already know these two first
two libraries so this is third library
is used for
web browser is the file source code the
web browser modules offers a high level
user interface that enables user to view
web-based content
in most cases executing the open
function from the this module will
result in the desired outcome
so moving forward let me write code for
it
so I will write code first then I will
explain you line wise
so I will write
if
underscore underscore
name
then again to underscore equals to
equals to
underscore main then again underscore
then colon
yeah then you have to give a path like
for your browser you can use Edge you
can use Google Chrome anything Firefox
anything
so here I will give path path equals to
then
C drive I have my path
already
program
files
and
X
Microsoft
and Edge
then
okay then
application
then msh
dot e x e
you have to write at the end this
percentage s
don't forget to write this
okay so path is set so let me create Sr
equals to
speech
recognition
Dot
recognizer
same as previous one
and I will write with
speech underscore
recognition
Dot microphone
as source
and Sr dot adjust
or
ambient
noise
then source
now everything seems good
let me write print
but we have wrote the like speak
now please so here I will write
please
a something
to open
okay
I will write audio
equals to
Sr Dot listen
that source
and I will print
like what you said
so it will here hearing
and I will here I try and accept
then try
so here I will write destination
equals to Sr
dot recognize
underscore Google
then audio
print
you asked
to open
right here Plus
destination
okay
so then web
browser
browser dot get
that path
then open
that destination
destination
okay
so here I will write that accept
caption
as
you can write e
then print
if there will be error
better
stia
e
okay
so I recognize the machine ability to
listen to spoken words and identify them
you can use speech recognition in Python
to convert the spoken word into text you
can even program some devices to respond
to these spoken words every time they
recognize the speech from mic function
is invoked the recognizer is calibrated
for changing noise condition using the
adjust ambient noise method
a socket is all ready to receive
connection after calling the listen
function prior to performing the accept
method on the server socket the listen
method should be called the backlog
parameter of the listen function allow a
queue size to be specified it will
listen to what we are speaking or saying
the recognize Google function on the
recognizer class which you have now
developed will be used to query the
Google web speech API and will convert
spoken words into text
recognize Google needs the argument
audio data in order to function properly
otherwise it will fail
okay
so okay so let's try this it's working
or not
let me run this
okay invalid syntax perhaps you forgot a
comma
okay let me see
that print
error
Inc it should be yeah
okay let me check this
foreign
let me run this again
valid syntax perhaps you forgot a comma
okay
try to run this again
to
okay let me remove this
I guess it will work fine
still
did input okay okay no issues
so here I will write
again
accept
ion
e
and
errors
TR okay I forgot to write plus okay okay
e
yeah now it will work fine
blue www.youtube.com
so here you can see YouTube is open
yeah
so we will try this one more time
www.facebook.com
so here you can see Facebook is open
one more last time
www.simplyland.com
on that note enhance your professional
prospects through enrollment in
postgraduate program in Ai and machine
learning from Simply learn offered in
partnership with both Purdue University
and IBM a choir sought after
competencies encompassing machine
learning deep learning natural language
processing computer vision reinforcement
learning generative AI prompt
engineering chat GPT and married of
other Cutting Edge topics one year of
experience is preferred to enroll in
this course hurry up and enroll Now find
the course Link in the description box
so renting CDs and DVDs reading local TV
listenings watching film strip
projectors or recordings all of this is
a thing of the past today all of the
world's biggest film collection have
been digitized and moved to the online
streaming services like Netflix HBO or
YouTube
these platform can now help us with what
is possibly the most difficult task of
all choosing a movie they have been
enhanced with AI powered capabilities
well that is no longer a concern for you
it is final time for machine learning to
put its skills on display in the modern
cinematic landscape
to create Advanced predictive system for
True movie expert data scientists are
prepared to investigate our behavioral
patterns and those of movies
a movie recommendation system also known
as a movie recommender system uses
machine learning to predict or filter
user fill preferences based on their
prior decision and actions it is an
advanced filtration system that
anticipate the consumer in question
potential like selection for a domain
specific item a movie
so after seeing what is movie
recommendation system let's move forward
and see how movie recommendation system
actually works a movie recommendation
system fundamental idea is a pretty
straightforward every recommender system
primarily consists of two components
users and items user receive more
prediction from the system and the
actual movies are the products filtering
and predicting only the movies that a
matching user is most likely to wish to
see in the main objective of movie
recommendation system the user
information from the system database is
used by the ml algorithm for these
recommendation system
based on information from the past this
data is used to forecast the user in
questions behavior in the future
data should be handled by expert because
it is so crucial to ml projects
including the movie recommendation
system
after seeing how movie recommendation
system works let's see some filtration
strategies for movie recommendation
system
to assist user in finding the most
relevant films movie recommendation
system employ a variety of filtration
techniques and algorithm
the content-based filtering and the
collaborative filtering system
subcategories of the ml algorithm used
for the movie recommendations are the
most well liked ones
filtering based on content or content
based filtering a method of filtering
movies in a movie recommendation system
that makes advantage of the item's data
this information which is taken from the
just one user is quite important in this
case
this technique uses an ml algorithm to
suggest movies that are comparable to
the user's past choices
therefore the information about the
prior movie choices and likes just one
person is used to generate similarity in
content-based filtering
and the second one is collaborative
filtering as the name implies this
filtering technique is based on the
interaction between the relevant person
and the other user for the best outcomes
the system contrasts and compare these
behaviors it combines the film choices
and uses patterns of several people
like there are two types of
collaborative filtering algorithm the
first one is collaborative filtering
based on users the goal is to find
patterns in Target users and other
database users like movie preferences
and the second one is collaborative item
based filtering the fundamental idea
behind this is to find comparable
products products like movies that
Target users rate or interact with so
after seeing the filtering strategies
for movie recommendation system so here
is one question for you guys
I will give you one minute for this you
can comment or you can give answer in
chat section so I can see if the answer
is given by you are right or wrong
I'm repeating again so here is one
question for you guys I will give you
one minute exactly one minute for this
you can comment or you can give your
answer in chat section so I can see if
the answers given by you are right or
wrong
so the question is
which is the best language for machine
learning programming
learning the first one is Java the
second one is python the third one is
our language and the fourth one is C
plus plus
so this is the question I am repeating
again which is the best language for
machine learning
though option one is Java second python
R language and C plus plus so I am
starting timer of one minute just type
your answers in comment section or in a
chat section do let me know your answers
please I want that everyone should
participate in this and make this live
session interesting
so I am starting timer
oh your time starts now
please guys do let me know your answers
in chat section or in you can comment
down
42 seconds to go
you can comment or you can give your
answer in the chat section so I can see
if the answer is given by you are right
or wrong
30 seconds more
which is the best language for machine
learning
you can give your answer chat section or
you can comment
so I can see if the answers given by you
are right or wrong guys come on please I
want that everyone should participate in
this and make this live section
interesting
come on guys five second more
one
yep time up
so time is over we will give reply those
who gave correct answer and those who
didn't give correct answer we will give
you a reply with the correct answer
so now let's move to our programming
part to perform movie recommendation
system using python
so first we will open command prompt to
write command to open jupyter notebook
so we will write Jupiter
notebook press enter
so this is the landing page of Jupiter
notebook and select here new
python file
so this is how jupyter notebook UI look
likes so at first we will import some
major libraries or python which will
help us in mathematical functioning so
so the first one is numpy import
numpy as NP
so number is a python Library used for
working with arrays it also has a
function for working in the domain of
linear algebra and matrices it is an
open source project and you can use it
freely numpy stands for numerical python
so here NPD in NP is denoting numpy so
we will import the next Library
both
pandas as
PD
is should be space yup
so
pandas is a software Library written for
the Python programming language for data
manipulation and Analysis in particular
it offers data structures and operation
for manipulating numerical tables and
time series so
so after importing libraries we will
move ahead and import data set so for
importing data set we have to write like
we have two data set with us
let me show you the data set we have two
data set with us
the first one is credits
this one
and the second one is movies one
movies one so don't worry you can get
these data set link in the description
box so let me write
here
credits
let's go data frame equals to PD dot
read
underscore CSV
here you have to give your location of
the data set
credits
dot CSV
the second one is movies
let's go data frame
this is for movie data frame PD dot read
ESP
so here you have to give the movie
location movie data set location movies
dot CSV
okay everything seems good
let me run this
yeah
so then
here PD is for the pandas Library read
is used for reading the data set from
the machine and CSV is used for the type
of file which you want to read
so after this let's write code to see
the data set so we will write here
credits underscore DF
and we will run it so this is our so
this is our credit data set and next one
is movies
underscore
so this is our movie data set
so this is how our board data set look
like so here you can see three dots
this one and here also
this one so we are unable to see our
full data set like what if we want like
full a 4803 rows
so at that case we can write here
PD Dot
set
underscore option
okay
and here we will write display
dot Max
underscore columns
this
and here we will write none
same for the rows PD dot set
option
display
dot Max
underscore rows
okay
none
let's run this
so now if we will write credits
underscore DF
it is running yeah
so now you can see your full data set
like full credit data set with 4803 rows
or four eight zero two rows because
there is
this is starting from zero that's why so
what about movies data set
okay wait running
it is still running you can see here
so here you can see the full data set
movie data set with 4802 rows
or if you want to see only five top rows
so you can write here credits underscore
DF dot hat
so by this
only five top rows so from head you we
can see our five top rows and if we will
use tail instead of head we can see our
last five rows so here let me do with
the movies one
DF Dot tail
yeah
so here you can see 4798 row four seven
nine and till 4802 so retail we can see
our last five rows
so moving forward let's merge the credit
data set to movie data set because if we
will combine them the confusion will be
less and at the end it will be better
for us so we will write here movies
underscore
equals to movies
underscore data frame and credits
underscore DF
on
it
okay T is a small I guess yeah perfect
title
so let me do something something like
this
okay
it is saying data frame object is not
callable
edits underscore DF
movies
okay why because
we haven't wrote merge here
now it will work
yeah perfect it's working so data is
merged let's see the number of rows and
column using share function so now we
have only one so movies underscore DF
dot shape
okay let's run it 4809 and 2 3 23 but if
we see here like in movies data set so
in movies data set here here yeah yeah
there are 20 and
in here we are four columns in credit
data set
so
like so you will be thinking that's why
not 24 why only 23 columns that is why
on title you can see here on title the
titles in both titles are same you can
see here
both titles are same
in both
let me show you like this
okay after Pirates of the Caribbean
Spectra and so on
here you can see after pirates of the
academy inspector and so on
so that is why on title
written while merging so titles are same
so moving forward let's see our merge
data set
so we will write only movies
underscore data frame dot hat
yeah
so our data is merged you can see
the last cast crew movie ID yeah you can
see here movie ID title are the same
they are most cast crew okay guys
let me give some more
for the better View
yeah
so you can see all Columns of credit
data set are added to movies one so
moving forward let's see another
function like
movies
underscore DF Dot info
so by this
yes you can see
so by this the data frame information is
printed via the info method the data
includes the total number of columns
their labels data kinds memory use rage
index and the number of cells in each
columns like non-null values note that
info method does indeed print the
information
so here you can see the all the
information is printed
okay
like columns name and the all null
values count and data types to like this
int object and
in which we are working most so after
this let's move forward and select some
main column in which you are working
most so we will write movies
underscore DF
equals to movies
foreign
comma and another one is overview
okay why
okay here we have to get like this yeah
so here we have to write John R
Jonah is complete and we will work on
what keywords keywords are the main
keywords okay keywords then
it will cost
then we will
we will do recommendation with the crew
as well
okay
so by running this let me see
our data again with seven okay okay
there is one error okay this is movie
a movie Radio Journal yeah not index
okay got it got it
why not genre
it's John it's I guess
what it is it's shown it's
that's why
it's Jonas okay
yeah so let's see our data again with
seven columns so I will write so I will
write here movies underscore DF
dot head
here
so you can see only our we have like
movies ID same title overview joiners
keywords cash and crew only
so here you you can see the selected
columns okay so let's move forward and
once again let's see the info again like
movies
underscore TF Dot
invoice come with selected columns and
let's move forward and see how many
missing values are present in particular
column so like the columns is full we
can see here but we don't know about
that four thousand eight zero three
values are filled or not so what we will
do it we will see how many missing
values are present there so
here we will write like movies
underscore DF dot is null
dot sum
not like this
yeah perfect
so the function data frame is null this
one is null dot sum dot sum Returns the
number of missing values in the data set
so here you can see overview have three
missing values
so what we can do is we can write here
movies
underscore DF
DF
Dot
drop n a
this
equals to
true
okay
we will run it with sayings okay words
documents
Pursuit true okay fine
and yeah it will not create an issue so
if you sat in place equals to true the
drop any method will modify your data
frame directly that means that if you
set in place equals to true the drop any
will drop all missing values from your
original data set let's move forward and
see movies
underscore DF
Dot
duplicated
so the duplicate method returns a series
with true on false
values that describe which rows in the
data frame are duplicated or not use the
subset parameter to specify if any
column should not be considered when
looking for duplicates
so
here let me run this first
so here we are we are getting 0. y 0 so
if you are like thinking there is no
true or false return so if you write it
without sum like if I will write it
without some
okay let me copy from here yeah and I
will run this so
here you can see
false false false in whole data set
so some will combine them and return you
a value at the end zero represent false
itself
so we need to not need this so we will
write something else
so moving forward let me write First
movies
underscore DF dot I location
Dot johnnets
let me run this
so the I log function this one ilock
function
first let me do something like this
it will go up okay huh
Okay so
from ilog function in Python is defined
in the pandas module that helps us to
select a specific row or column from the
data set
using the ilock method in Python we can
easily retrieve any particular value
from a row or column by using index
value so here zeroth position line is
coming
which is here you can see
so name action like name action name
Adventure name fantasy this PSI
physician
this one science fiction yeah so this is
because I am giving here Jonah that is
why you can see here
see id28 name action name something
something like that okay
so
let's import something called ASG
abstract Syntax for tree
so this is one of the major Library
import AST
let me run this import is a class
defined is the AST module that is used
to express the import statement in
python in the form of abstract syntax
tree so
so an abstract syntax tree or just
syntax tree is a tree representation of
the of the abstract syntactic structure
of text written in a formal language
each node of the trade denotes a
construct occurring in the text
so let's convert some like literal to
object and append them so here I will
write Def
convert
obj object
like l
equals to
blank array
for I in
St Dot
natural
bit
J object
okay
l dot append
return
here we are converting is like here is a
convert is a function and L is the array
to append by using for Loop we can
append them to name so let me write code
then I will explain like what is
happening so let me write full code so
movies
underscore DF
donors
okay
because your movies
journals
and then dot apply
what
so then movies underscore TF
then I will write keywords
let's do movies
underscore DF
keywords
lie
score DF Dot
so if we will see our old data set in
that like we will see old data set in
that journal and that's keyword this
keyword
apps ID name and so on like ID that name
like this type of things so it will
create a message retrieving them so by
using AST Library we just convert them
to the normal one like title so got it
guys so I hope you guys understand till
here if you have any question or any
query regarding any code or question
just put as in comment our team will
shortly provide you the correct solution
attributing again I hope you guys
understand till here if you have any
type of questions regarding any code or
something
so just put as in comments our team will
shortly provide you the correct solution
so moving forward let's convert cash to
and like same as previous way like like
this only
so what we will do here we will write
def
convert
them
here I am using
so l equals to
counter equals to zero
St
dot literal
if counter
does not
equals to 3
then
l dot
Dot
dot append okay then here I have to
write I
to name
counter
equals to 1.
if you want to write like count as
equals to counter plus one it is like
both the same
else
click
done
l
so let me run this let me run this
okay so after this a small code we have
to assign the values like
we are doing it for Costner so movies
okay moves
let's go DF then cast
let's show movies
underscore DF
asked
Dot
reply
convert
everything seems good
so let's see the changes are visible or
not so we will write here movies
underscore TF
dot hat
you can ignore this like this is nothing
so here you can see cast is also
same like keyword and journal so like
let's do for the creo2 so like we are
converting you can say in a structured
way
so let's do for the crew one two so let
me put some
yeah
so here we will add depth like fetch
which is nothing like
a function name as director
obj
colon l equals to
or i n s t Dot literal
obj
if
I
talk
equals to
like we can hit director
so then
l dot append
um
dot append to the same name
but
return
okay capital l
so we have to again write that movies
equals to movies
in
crew
lie
h
just remember fetch director is a
function name let's see changes
so here I have to write movies then
press enter
so yeah crew is all set so
changes are visible and data is looking
good so what we like if I want to see
the first movie Avatar overview this
like this dot dot dot so I have to write
here
like movies
overview
Overview at zeroth
place
so yeah
so this is a full overview of avtar
movie like let me read for this in this
2017 Century uh paraplegic Marine is
dispatched and blah blah blah blah and
civilization
so moving forward that what we want to
recommend movie in the basis of overview
Joiner keyword cars so for that we need
a separate separate words like in the
then 22nd century alone
so if you will see in other columns all
the words are separated but like here if
you will see all the words are separated
like action is separated Adventure is
separated fantasy it's separated
so
there is a long sentence in this this
one in the over V1 there's a long
sentence
so it's difficult to recommend from this
so what we are going to do is well we
will separate them like like other
columns so here we will write
movies
overview
was to movies
and overview
and Dot apply
my bad sorry
then Lambda
colon x dot
split
error so let's see the results so movies
yeah you can see in the Saturn so now
you can see all the words are separated
by comma so now it will easy to match
overview to recommend a particular movie
so moving forward so what we are going
to do is if there is a two word and
space between there so we are going to
remove that space so here you can see
science fiction are separate separate
okay so we are going to re like remove
this one this space
so let's write code for that
so here I will write like
overview is already done so we will do
not do for that so let's write code for
the rest columns
so here I have to write
movies
like
Jonas
pursue movies
and again
Jonas
dot apply
Lambda
X
I dot replace
mom
to no space
oh it seems good
then I have to write for
everywhere so for I in x
it's 4i in x 4 I in x
movies genres equals to movie genres dot
apply Lambda X
I dot replace this to this for
same score
so let's copy paste this see
one for keywords and one for cast and
crew
it's
happened
last
first
that you
that's the same so let me run this
okay no error seems good so let's see
the changes so movies
so now you can see the science fiction
space is gone like here is science
fiction space is there
now science fiction space is gone
so like uh okay
let's move forward and create one new
column name as tag and put all the
column data in a particular column
okay let me do first yeah let me write
movies
[Music]
then first we will put overview
Plus movies
and Jonas
and movies
and what we have to give keywords
keywords
then again
movies
then
asked
let me run this
okay
so let's see the data frame movies
okay still coming so like there is one
problem I guess
yeah no no no
so here you can see all the data is
merged in a under attack column yes you
can see like in the second sensory blah
blah blah so
I hope you guys understand till here if
you have any question or any query
regarding any code
or anything just put as in comment or
our team will shortly provide you the
correct solution okay so I'm repeating
again I hope you guys understand till
here if you have any question or any
query regarding any code or like any
question just put as in comment our team
will shortly provide you the correct
solution
so from here let's create a new data
frame
so let me create new data frame because
now we don't need this overview car
screw Joiner like columns like this we
have already merged into a one one
column like attack column so we will
write here new
DF equals to movies
so
like movies we need movie ID
new data frame we need movie ID comma we
need Title
and we have everything in tag column tax
column so we need tax column
okay let's run this let's see our new
data frame
so this is our new data look likes with
only three columns like movie ID title
and tags so here you can see array
brackets like this this area brackets
so
we are gonna remove them so we will do
what we will write here we will write
new
data frame
that n tags
equals to
new
data frame
tags
dot apply
Lambda
X
then I will give space
dot join
seems good everything is okay okay fine
yeah
so let's see the results so
we will write a new underscore data
frame
so you can see the brackets are removed
now let's see the data which is present
in the zeroth index intact column like
this dot dot in this
okay for that we have to write here
uh new
data frame
tax
we did it before like for the overview
one so you have to yeah
so this is the whole data in the first
like first index zeroth index so some
part of the overview like from
civilization and some are you can see
this action Advantage fantasy science
fiction these are some like genres
and
like here you can see like these are
some Crews members
and
yeah like Sam Worthington like there are
some cast crew okay
so like moving forward like what we are
going to do is just make them in lower
case for the better prediction like
something in capital and something like
smaller so let's make it to
lowercase so new underscore DF
tax
equals to new underscore DF
dot apply
da
score in x dot lower
okay
so don't worry about this error
let's see the result new underscore DF
Dot
yeah now all the data present at TAG
column is in small case or you can say
lowercase moving forward let's do some
feature extraction using count
vectorizer so
let's let me write first from SK learn
Dot feature
instruction
feature extraction okay cool
dot text
import
count
vectorizer
TV equals to
count
riser
underscore
features
equals to
5000.
oh
words
equals to
English
and this
yeah
so count vectorizer
okay there is a
that cannot import count vectorizer from
SQL and from user
okay okay sorry sorry my bad here V is
capital
okay guys so he B is capital yeah so no
error so count vectorizer is a great
tool provided by the scikit-learn
library in Python it is used to
transform a given text into a vector on
the basis of the frequency count
of each word that occurs in the entire
text so
let me write something CV Dot
with underscore
transform
f
X like dot to array
shape
okay
so the fit method like learn some
vocabulary dictionary of all tokens in
the Raw documents that is it creates a
dictionary of tokens by default the
tokens are word separated by spaces and
like punctuation so that Maps each
single token to a position in the output
vectors so here CVS are like here CV is
a counter vectorizer so let's convert
into Vector to array so for this we have
to write vectors
vectors equals to CV dot fit
yeah then transform
X
sin
so here we have to write
Dot
to array
yeah then we have to write
vector
its vectors
yeah you can see Vector two array all
the zeros
okay so moving forward let's get the
feature Name by writing
yeah so we will write here
lien LAN
CV dot get
feature
names
which are names okay then bracket
yeah
so okay we have like 500 feature names
so I'm repeating I'm saying again like I
hope you guys understand Taylor if you
have any question or any query regarding
any code whatever it is so just put us
in comments our team will shortly
provide you the correct solution
okay guys like any code or you are not
understand anything just put as in
comment our team will shortly provide
you the correct solution
so let's import some major Library which
is import
nltk
so what is nltk the natural language
toolkit nltk is a platform used for
building python programs that work with
human language
for applying in a statical network
language processing NLP it contain text
processing libraries for tokenization
parsing classification stemming tagging
and semantic reasoning
so moving forward like from let me write
first from
and nltk
dot stem
dot Porter
import
Porter
yes equals to
water
I mean is a process for reducing a word
to its word stem that suffix and prefix
or to the roots of words known as Alama
stamming is important in natural
language understanding nlu and natural
language processing NLP
so here like I have to write
so here I will write def stem
to text
y
equals to
or I in
text Dot split
y dot append
dot stem
done
dot join
y
so let's apply this timing to attack
column so here we will write new DF
X
equals to
new
if
tag
dot apply
um
so let's import a cosine similarity from
SK learn so here we will write from SK
learn
dot matrices
Dot pairwise
import
cosine
underscore see me clarity
okay it seemed good from SQL and
matrices
metrics sorry Matrix Dot peer-wise it is
[Music]
pairwise import question similarity okay
let's run this no error so cosine
similarity measures the similarity
between two Factor I repeat cosine
between two vectors of an inner product
space it is measured by the cosine of
the angle between two vectors and
determines whether two vectors are
pointing in roughly the same direction
it is often used to measure document
similarity in text analysis so here we
will write
cosine
underscore Simi
clarity
vectors
so these all are the vector present
let's see the cosine similarity Vector
column and row using space
so here I will write cosine
let's go see similarity
vectors
dot shape
so it's still running you can see here
yeah
so 4806 rows and four eight zero six
columns are there let's assign variable
similarity to this
okay so let's similarity
will write like this so let it goes to
cosine
similarity
is underscore here
I did this because we don't have to
write always this long sentence a long
keyword you can say
so moving forward let's see First Column
like we will add similarity
yeah so this is our first column uh so
let's see the rows only so we will write
here
parity
zero
Dot
shape
okay 4806 okay
so let's move forward and let's create
some like sorted list so
for that sorted
okay
paste
enumerate
spelling is fine
okay one more like Simi laity
similarity
zero
that I have to write reverse
equals to true
comma key
equals to Lambda
colon
x dot capital x x
to write one
one colon six
seems good yeah
so the enumerate function in Python
converts a data collection object into
an enumerate object enumerate returns an
object that contains a counter as a key
for each value with an object making
item within a collection easier to
access so finally let's create the
recommend function to check the movie
recommendation system
okay
so
so let's write here d f
recommend
we
also new
DF
in the TF
I tell
equals equals to movie
X
zero
tenses
versus similarity
and movie
okay so movies
list equals to sorted
Emirate
r80 number eight
distances
reverse
was so
true
keyword
sorry key only okay
equals to Lambda
colon X
and
colon six
or
I in movies
list
dot I lock
I
dot title because we need Title only
so yeah it seems good okay
so finally that like time is game
so finally the time has come to check
the recommendation of your favorite
movies so you can comment in the chat
section so I can check
so let me write first recommend
the command for movie
Avatar
okay
so here you can see the recommendation
system is working fine so Titan a DOT e
small soldier Independence they are the
recommendation for the movie after
so let me check for the another one
recommend
like for
one of my favorite movie Iron Man
so here you can see Iron Man 2 Iron Man
3 Avengers Age of Ultron Captain America
and the Avengers are just
recommendations for the movie Iron Man
so let me check for the one more
recommend
Liars
liar
things going on 30 and the last one is
last one I want to check is
Captain America Civil War
let me copy from here only
yeah you can see the Captain America the
First Avenger the Winter Soldier Iron
Man 3 age of ultron's The Avengers
did you know Microsoft is planning to
invest 10 million dollars in charge gbt
developer even silicon Valley's biggest
conglomerates have begun to take note of
charge GPT versatility and practicality
people have started earning money
through chargeability and some even
predict the Revolutionary AI chatbot
will replace Google search but what
makes charge ability so resourceful what
chargibility is and how it works and at
the end we will discuss some of the ways
that chair GPT is being used in the real
world the potential implications of this
technology from chat boards to language
translation chat gbt has many
applications that make it easier for
businesses and individuals to interact
with technology so hello everyone I am
bank and welcome to Simply learn make
sure you are subscribed to our Channel
and hit that Bell icon to stay updated
with the latest technological Trends
before we move on to the demo part let's
discuss what chargibility is and proceed
further for the same so what is
chargeability chargability position
language model created by open AI it is
a form of generative pre-trained
transformed gbt model which was trained
on a data set of conversational problems
such as dialogue Snippets and chat logs
the model is capable of generating
human-like responses to text input so
now let's understand how charge gbt
actually works this model is pre-trained
on a large tax data set and then fine
tune on a smaller data set specific to
the everyday task when the model
receives input from a user it uses the
pattern it learned during fine tuning to
generate a response let's take another
example the model can generate an
appropriate response even if the input
is not a complete question or a sentence
after seeing what is chargeability and
how it works now moving forward let's
see how we can use shared GPT in our
day-to-day life
so this is a Google search here we will
write
chat dot open AI
.com
it will take time
so this is the chat window UI of the
chargpt
so our first use case is chargpt can
explain complex subjects okay so first
we will ask like what
is neuroscience
it will take time
it's taking time to load because many of
the users are using
it started Neuroscience is the
scientific study of the nervous system
which includes the brain it will write
all about the Neuroscience you can ask
anything any subject okay like Heart to
Heart easy any or even you can stop
generating two if you want to
okay so this is how you can ask like any
question to the any complex question to
charge gbt okay uh we'll ask one more
like what is
quantum
it's loading
I don't know why it's taking time
because of net issue or I don't know why
take time and it will come
that uses properties of quantum
mechanics to perform operations on data
like this okay
two states zero or one and all the
quantum Computing knowledge
okay
so this is how you can ask anything like
any com about any complex subject to the
charge ability okay
so with chat our Second Use cases we can
write code using chat GPT okay we can
write so here I will give give me
a machine
learning
program
collection
okay press enter
okay so here it's started here is a
simple Python program that uses
saturated learn Library there's this and
this
this is how you can take write a code
any code if you ask anything like
sorting like add two numbers
or palindrome
anything you can anything you can ask
from chargibility it will give you a
code proper code
edit right please note that this is a
simple example of sort prediction is a
complex task and this example is not
enough to make a good prediction it
would need a lot more data feature
engineering and model tuning to make
accurate prediction Okay so
let me give another Java
implementations implementation
of the what bubble
I'll go to them okay
let me ask this
yeah it started like here is a Java
implementation of the bubble sort
algorithm
so
give you proper runnable algorithm
okay like bubble sort
to give you fully
you can ask any type of code any type of
like apis anything
it will explain to this implementation
using nested Loop to compare adjacent
elements in the area and swipe them if
they are in the wrong order
okay
Angela after the outer loop completes
the array will be sorted in ascending
order our third use case is we can debug
the code okay so for that
but I will I will take this one code
okay I will take this code
and
here I will write debug the code and I
will paste it here
and what I will do I will instead of
temp
here
I will like I will write
okay I will add 2p okay so now
what it will do charge it will do it
will develop see the error in the code
is in the this line
it should be temp
you can see here
it is stamp
so from charity you can debug the error
okay you can have the conversation with
to pull the charge body like if you have
any question you can directly write
what's wrong in the other question like
this okay like you have an extra p in
this variable name which is causing a
compile error this is because temp is
the variable that you declared earlier
to store the value of current element
whereas temp is not a variable that has
been declared so here you can see
the stamp is declared here so that is
that the error is causing the code not
to run once you fix the issue okay like
sort the arrange or sending whatever
okay so using chat GPT you can easily
debug your errors the code and it is
very helpful on your project building
okay so fourth use case is you can
create custom marketing plans or
strategy okay I'm repeating again you
can create custom marketing plans or
strategy like how so here I will write
how
could
remote
videos
on
social
media
present
it will give you proper plan how you can
promote your YouTube videos on your
social media
okay
I will chat with this okay I will ask
some question
views engagement everyone knows there
are a few strategies you can use C per
second and more like more to come like
share your video on personal social
media accounts us include your Facebook
Twitter Instagram and other accounts
thing like that join the 11 communities
and groups through use social media ads
platform like Facebook and stuff
Instagram and Twitter
collaborate with influencer it is also
true create a hashtag for your videos
use YouTube video build-in sharing
features
it will give you all the marketing plans
it can create marketing plans any type
of plans
see remember your video should be
engaging information and should we
provide value to our audience
it is something like that now I will ask
one question to chargeability
Okay so
I will ask what
if
make
only
travel videos
okay
what if I will make only okay
travel videos
so how
should
I
capture
p
odium
you can ask any type of question okay
relevant to
this question or this answer you got
okay now let's see
it will give you everything if you are
making travel videos there are like few
strategies you can use to capture and
engage your audience
like this okay so the unique interesting
aspect of the destination you visit
people are often thrown to new and
unique experience like say share your
personal experience and insights it will
give you a proper plan
like how you can increase your audience
engage your audience okay
collaborate other travel bloggers that's
true engage with Audience by responding
to comments messages through
remember your video should be visually
appealing and provide valuable
information to your audience it is also
important to be authentic and true to
yourself like that okay so this is how
you can like using charity how you can
create your marketing plans or your
something like that okay so our fifth
use case is we can generate articles and
blogs using chair GPT okay so let me ask
right and
article
Sheen
learning
because everybody is also machine
learning kind of machine learning
on machine learning
in
500 Words
Pleasanton
it will write only exactly like 500
Words it will give you only 500 words
like machine learning is rapidly growing
field that is transforming the way we
live and work it is a branch of
artificial intelligence blah blah
basic idea of machine learning is that
computers can learn from data without
being explicitly programmed
like supervising is the most common type
of the machine learning just through
yeah you can see here there are three
main types of machine learning
supervised learning and supervise any
enforcement
it's true it will tell about it will
write a proper
article in only 500 word not more than
that
machine learning has a potential
application Healthcare machine learning
patient data and more accurate diagnosis
like that
500 Words
it will give you exactly 500 Words
and conversion machine learning is
rapidly growing field that has the
portion to professionalize many
Industries it allows computers to learn
from the data without being explicitly
programmed
this is 500 Words of article
okay you can ask write article videos
descriptions blogs any kind of content
writing you can see
okay so let's do one more question and
the same so I will like give me
money
on
to write
okay skip for my YouTube
Channel
YouTube channel YouTube shorts
videos
video on Cyber
security
okay
so here is a short skip for funny
YouTube video on cyber security
like narrator
where every clip could be your last
exactly
so something like that
always use strong password like password
One Two Three or quality
right the tip number two never click on
suspicious link unless it's linked to be
to free pizza
see this is how you can create your
funny
how you can generate your content from
chargpt using chargity okay
thanks for watching stay safe out there
please note that this description just
for fun to greatly be known and not mean
to be taken seriously it's important to
take cyber security seriously and follow
best practices to protect your person
and professional data
okay
so this is how you can write
your make your content so easily like by
writing the title of the content so our
six use cases you can even Summarize the
book or article using child Liberty like
how I will write here summarize
the book
believer's travel
University
novel written by Jonathan Swift in this
the book does the story of limel
Gulliver a ship surgeon who becomes
Shipwrecked it will light only it will
summarize all about delivered travel
yeah in part one this happened
Oliver washes up on the island of
teleportia exactly
do this happen and part three discipline
because this is how you can summarize
any book any related to like educational
no world fiction any type of book or
article and blogs
okay whatever you want to summarize
page will run the book is being
commented on the Society of ship to one
time
okay so this is how you can Summarize
the book goalie master
our seventh use cases we can ask
interview question two using charity so
here I can ask how to answer
premiere
of yours what
is
your
weakness
okay
so when answering the question it is the
best to be honest but also to frame your
answer in a positive way yeah exactly
for example you could say something like
I have a tendency to be perfectionate
and sometimes struggle with delegating
tasks however I have been working on
this learning like this you can ask any
question any interview type question
okay related to HR or technical anything
you can ask
so let's see
how
to
answer
the
web viewer
like where do you see yourself
in next
five years
take
when answering this question it's good
idea to be align your answer with the
company's course and values yeah exactly
for example you could say something like
in five years I can see myself going
within the company and taking more
responsibility exactly
so this is how
you can ask any type of HR questions
you are facing off okay
so our next
use cases
our AIDS use cases we can develop apps
using charitivity
okay yes we can develop apps using
chargeability like
I want
to write
an Android
app that
shows me
please talk
prices
as a
list
um
let's see Yahoo
API
okay
or how can
I do
like this so it will write a proper
Android app code
for you
with a new Android project or it will
give you a proper idea how you can make
a you know app
all these steps
from starting to the last
choose a view holder to hold the
reference of the views for each item in
the list
okay
use asynchronous stars to fetch all the
step from starting to the end
this is a brief overview of the steps
and you will need to take a build
Android app
okay
okay so this is how you can like ask
anything to create
a
okay using any language Java python any
language okay I repeat our ninth use
case is we can create our exercise plan
diet plan using charge ability okay
so I would like my width is 25 okay
let's take
25 kg
and I want to
lose
create
seven days
period seven days
plan
for
the advice
I
plan for it
okay
it will get see here is a day exercise
and the diet plan that can help you do
day one exercise 30 minute risk walk or
joke right start your day with healthy
breakfast of oatmeal berries like this
it will create exactly seven days
okay so this is our ninth use case we
can make any type of plant diet plan
food plan exercise plan or anything
marketing strategy
anything you want
timetable
of focusing something anything you can
make
and according to you yourself you can
rearrange them okay it will be very easy
and it is very time saving
okay if we create seven days plan
there's X exercise training session like
this type
is you want to lose
avocado toast with post deck
so it's important to note that this is
just a plan Simple Plan
so our tense use cases last use case you
can ask any General Knowledge Questions
to chat gbt like
okay who invented
first
frustrated by German Goldsmith yeah
you can cross question to charge be the
answer
okay
this is the all the use case of
chargeability like
it can or debug the code audit the code
like explain complex subject create
custom marketing plan or strategy diet
plan exercise plan you can generate your
content like article blogs you can
Summarize the book and the Articles or
interview question preparation or
developing apps coding
you can easily do with the charge GPD
okay I hope you understand how to use
chat GPT and what is charge GPT okay and
the use cases of child GPT and where you
can use in day-to-day life on that note
enhance your professional prospects
through enrollment and postgraduate
program in Ai and machine learning from
Simply learn offered in partnership with
both Purdue University and IBM acquire
sought after competencies encompassing
machine learning deep learning natural
language processing computer vision
reinforcement learning generative AI
prompt engineering chat GPT and married
of other cutting-edge topics one year of
experience is preferred to enroll in
this course hurry up and enroll Now find
the course Link in the description box
the evolution of natural language
processing has come a long way today we
have a variety of AI language models
that are fully operational and have the
potential not just to decode your
question but also smart enough to
understand the intention behind your
questions are the countless number of
development and the emerging ones like
Megatron Albert Electra T5 and many more
these three models are currently ruling
the space of AI language models Bing
Bard and charity and today we will
understand the differences similarities
and the abilities that make them stand
out and try to decide which one is the
best hey everyone welcome to Simply
launch YouTube channel and today we
bring you the Bing versus the Google bar
the chat GPD but before we begin if
these are the type of videos you would
like to watch hit that subscribe button
and the bell icon to never miss an
update from Simply learn if you are an
aspiring artificial intelligence
engineer looking for an online training
and certification from the prestigious
universities and in collaboration with
leading experts so that you have the
most robust Foundation skills knowledge
and what it takes to become the best
then search no more simply learns post
graduation program in artificial
intelligence from Purdue University in
collaboration with IBM should be your
right choice for more details use the
link in the description box below also
want to get access to more informative
content like this one get subscribed to
us and hit the Bell so that you are the
first to get to know when we host with
that in mind let's start with the
elephant in the room that is the chat
gbd
was released on the 30th of November
2022 it uses the GPT llm to elaborate
llm as an abbreviation for large
language model and chat jpd is globally
available to its users using the
generative pre-trained Transformer also
called as chat GPT llm with 1 trillion
parameters as its variables learned
during the model training now the Bing
Microsoft was one of the largest
investors in open AI Bing is an AI
language model created in collaboration
with open Ai and publicly released on
the 4th of May 2023 Bing uses the same
data set that chat GPD uses Bing has an
h o HR GPT as Microsoft integrates its
Prometheus with about 135 billion
parameters now next up we have Bard Bard
is Google's answer to chat gbd with
limited capabilities and lukewarm
responses it was released on 21st of
March 2023 but initially started off
with Lambda llm with a caliper of 137
billion parameters Google's CEO eshos
Bard will switch to pathway model named
as palm 2 llm with about 400 billion
plus parameters to take on chat GPD
head-on head in generating responses and
the application codes and Pro programs
with the details discussed let's move
ahead to some of the important
parameters to be considered to discuss
the differences firstly user interface
and experience chat GPD has a simple and
subtle interface making it easy to
understand and get along with the usage
so chat gpt's user interface looks
something like this chatgpt has a simple
Dark theme interface focusing on
providing users with high quality
language processing capabilities rather
than immersive visuals you can ask
questions get answers and even you can
ask to enhance or optimize the answer
according to your needs again user needs
to manually request chat GPD the other
hand Bing is more inclined towards
giving a blissful visual experience to
their users by choosing brilliant
background images colorful interfaces
and emojis
so a typical Wing user interface looks
something like this in addition to that
it is backed up by chat gpd's dataset
and Prometheus llm to help users with
the best in class answers to their
questions it even delivers three
different answers at the same time
creative balanced and precise are the
three variants and you can choose the
best ones which suits your requests now
lastly but bar is a little different
from others unlike others but just dumps
the answers at once enthusiasts call it
fast but it misses the human touch of
giving the answers in a word by word
typing minor yet similar to Bing it
manages to give you different versions
of the answers besides that but has a
decent interface and its logo shines
with multiple colors giving you the
feeling of part processing the data to
give you a better result now let's try
to ask a few most frequently asked
questions
let's ask with a simple one are you
friends with
Chad GPD
and Bing
you can see The Shining logo of Bart and
you have just seen the way how Google
bot answers you it just dumps the answer
now if you go or if you ask the same
question to the other one select charge
gbd and Bing let's see how they respond
and you can see you have other drives as
well right so you can see traffic on
graph 2 and draft three so you can
choose any ones which you feel are more
optimized and you know deliverable
according to your requests right now
let's go back to
think right now let's ask the same
question
are you friends with
chat GPD
and but
see the word by word typing approach of
Bing and charge APD gave you a little
more immersive feeling that somebody is
really talking to you right and you also
have the freedom of
choosing the answer wisely right so it
gives you three different options which
are creative balanced and precise right
and on just one single scroll you have
the Bing search open here right this is
one other good way of using Bing in the
in case if you have any questions that
are unanswered or which did not satisfy
you you can also go back to bring and
you can manually search for the data and
get the information right now let's get
back to chat GPD
here let's ask this in question
are you friends with
Bing and bad
me
so that's how individual AI models
respond to each other and now let's get
back to the next point of discussion
which is what is the data or history
about the questions you asked or the
prompts you have opened that each one of
these stores
so this is about the conversation
history or the prompt that you have with
intuition one of these AI models
first comes the chat GPD charge gbd
claims they do not store any data about
its interaction with its users but in
chat GPD you can access the prompts and
questions you asked you can also export
your transcripts in chat GPD on the
other hand we have bing bing says they
do not have any history or prompts of
your previous conversations as well and
lastly but but is a little mix and match
of both so what Bard does is it Stores
Only the prompts whereas in chat GPT
when you ask a question it will store
the question and the onsite gave you but
but it will only store The Prompt that
is the question you asked and note the
answer it gave to you so with that the
next point of discussion would be the
mobile version of each one of these as
of now Chad gbd hasn't released any of
the official mobile application version
yet and on the other hand on wing it has
just one click of a button and you can
click it and then Launches on your
mobile phone and when has a mobile
variant with similar and much better
Aesthetics that can get started on a
touch of an app launcher and lastly we
have bought bird has a similar approach
to its mobile variant Google has enabled
part usage in Google mobile application
as well and now comes the number of
questions asked disclaimer if you want
to work on a project presentation or
thesis choose your AI model wisely
because if you are close to wrapping up
your project and the AI model says sorry
pal you're out of your wishes Yes you
heard me right a few of these language
models have a limitation on the number
of questions asked on one single topic
or one single keyword or one single
concept let's look into details before
we proceed to the next part of this
video let's take a minute to hear from
our Learners who have experienced
massive success in their careers hey I'm
Sharia Jaleel I live in Ontario Canada I
have been in I.T sector for the past 20
years I recently took the professional
certificate program in artificial
intelligence and machine learning the
course has changed the way I look at
things and helped me back some amazing
freelance projects I started my career
in 1999 and over the years I have worked
with many companies my last tenor was
with IBM Canada my aim was to restart my
carrier and learn something that would
help accelerate my career
I thought artificial intelligence can
make me Future Ready
the course in artificial intelligence
and machine learning is provided by
simply learn in association with Purdue
University which is why I chose the
course I did not have high expectations
from online course but my experience was
simply awesome the quality of
interaction within the course was simply
amazing the course faculty was also very
experienced and knowledgeable
the course my knowledge has grown
manifold I have immensely benefited from
Python and coding skills I am able to
get some new freelance projects
also I am planning to start
an AI based startup with my friend where
I feel that the learning from the course
to be very helpful I am really delighted
and happy in my free time I try to
create meaningful content on YouTube and
I talk about new technologies and what
kind of courses professionals should be
taking along with many other topic I
definitely recommend this course to
everyone after all when it comes to new
skills to advance your career there
should be no compromise you should
always learn from the band
[Music]
first comes chat gbd chat GPD takes 25
questions on a single keyword or a
single subject or a single topic of
discussion post that it refrains from
answering your questions same with Bing
it takes no more than 20 questions on
single keyword or a single topic or a
single concept
but now comes Brad
Brad is a little different Brad kind of
said Stakes a little too high it almost
has no limits to your questions you can
ask any number of questions to God and
that can be a real deal breaker lastly
we will differentiate these AI models
based on their productivity yes exactly
we do know all these three models are
smart but how smart exactly how humanly
are they how close are they in
convincing you with an optimistic answer
what's their potential to charge a
hypothetical question and give you a
balanced answer sounds interesting right
let's get started first let's start with
chat gbd so let's say I want to learn Ai
and machine learning so obviously this
should be able to teach me that let's
ask it
can you
teach me
artificial intelligence
machine learning
brilliant it gave me a brief about
artificial intelligence machine learning
types of machine learning and deep
learning in one group and it also
convince you here right yes as an AI
model I can certainly help you with that
right so it's a good answer now let's
try to ask a little different one
or
can it plan a night meeting or can it
buy me a product online or can it do
some other things like booking me an
Uber right so let's try 10 new
or change
online
training program
for
Ai and ml
brilliant charge GPA knows its limits
right as an AI model I cannot directly
purchase online right it's giving you
the brutal truth here that's good and
apart from that it also gave you a
step-by-step procedure for buying your
course to your research check the
curriculum check the instructor what's
the format what's the cause right a few
parameters which you might want to
consider before buying a course right so
now let's try to question the same
queries to Wing So since Bing and chat
GPT share the same training data set I
could expect a similar answer but let's
see it is taking a while I guess
Prometheus is a little slower compared
to GPD okay there might be a connection
issue let's ask the question once again
wow it's way too better than charge EBD
so it is even asking you details on if
you if you are looking for a specific
topic or a general overview let's say I
would need a general overview
I could straight away say Bing is a
little more smarter and productive
compared to chat jpd but still we have
one more Contender to compare with but
right
so there might be again the internet
connection
now let's say we refresh Bing once again
and straight away ask the second
question what we had right that is can
you buy me a course
online
course
for learning
artificial
since
I think did gave me a good answer for
the previous question let's see what
kind of an answer it gives me now I'm
sorry but I'm not capable of making
online which is however I can find you
some online courses for learning AI
would you like me to search for some
options
brilliant
so this is a little more optimized
answer compared to chat GPD once and it
is also honest it does know its limits
fine it can help you search for some
online courses but again a chart GPD
gave us some parameters to consider
right so I would give or I would choose
to tie them up here they are on a tie
now our last Contender that is part
let's try to ask the same questions to
part so here is bad now let's try to ask
questions too but let's say can you
teach me
machine learning
you can see the bad logo shining there
now it should be dumping the answer
anytime soon yeah of course we do miss
that humanly Touch of giving the answer
in our word by word typing way
let's refresh and ask the question again
can you teach me
learning
this is a little too straightforward I'm
a language model and don't have the
capacity to help you out
so
okay let's not give up here let's try to
ask the second question can you purchase
an online
training program
to me
to learn
machine learning
yes I can help you purchase an online
program for machine learning here are a
few things that you need to consider
good
it's not being brutally honest here it
is saying it can help you out so again
what I intended to expect here was you
cannot just directly buy an online
program right you need some details
credentials and everything to purchase
so again it is the answer and it is
definitely giving you suggestions
similar to chat GPD but a little
different which focuses on your learning
style level of experience your budget
good nice way to answer some questions
like this one so all these three ones
are brilliant and good in their own way
so it might be a little difficult to
declare host the winner as of now since
the bad AI model is going to switch to
pump 2 and we are expecting some updates
to each one of these with that we can
consider currently they are standing
next to each other with similar
capabilities and better enhancement in
different fields so with that having
said we can conclude this session on
chat GPD versus Link versus Bart and if
you would like me to answer the
conclusion I would say well it seems
like we all have our strengths and
weaknesses at the end of the day it
comes to word users value the most that
they want a visually appealing interface
strong privacy protections or the
ability to converse with an AI language
model it's up to them to decide so you
are the viewers and you can decide the
winner of this particular battle on chat
gbd vs Bing versus bad and with that
having said if you are an aspiring
artificial intelligence engineer looking
for online training and certifications
from the prestigious universities and in
collaboration with leading experts so
that you have the most robust
foundations skills knowledge and what it
takes to become the best then search no
more simply launch postgraduate program
and artificial intelligence from Caltech
University in collaboration with IBM
should be your right choice for more
details use the links in the description
box below if you are looking for ways to
generate passive income without putting
in too much effort thanks to the
advancement in artificial intelligence
and chatbots it's now possible to earn
money using these Technologies in this
video we'll explore some of the
effective ways to generate passive
income with Charity charity is known for
being the world's smartest generative Ai
and is changing the game when it comes
to making money online with this
revolutionary free tool you can earn
with little skill and no Capital
required there is an exciting New Era of
artificial intelligence and now is the
perfect time to get involved and take
advantage of this opportunity people are
using charge apt for YouTube blogging
freelancing and for many other ways to
make money so let's dive in and discover
how to make money using shared deputy
and generate various passive incomes
there are variety of ways that you can
make money using charity we'll discuss
few of them in this video and we'll
start with first we'll see the list of
all the ideas from which you can make
money the first is get business ideas
from chat Jeopardy second is freelancing
third is build a software fourth is
boost your affiliate marketing with chat
Jeopardy's email expertise fifth is
leverage charge ability for blogging
success the next is unlock the potential
of charge Deputy for affiliate marketing
and then we have utilize strategory for
ebook writing and self-publishing this
is the main thing what people are doing
to make money using charitivity and then
we have utilized chat everybody to
enhance your YouTube channel and then we
have writing lyrics for music so
starting them one by one we'll start
with get business ideas from chat
Jeopardy by getting to know your
interest talent and obstacles chat
Jeopardy can generate tailored business
Concepts that align with your
expectations let's Dive Right In and ask
Chad Jeopardy for some business ideas
for a computer science engineer who has
experience in digital marketing and
sales are chat repeating and ask him
that I am a
computer science graduate the computer
science engineer
with experience in sales and marketing
and what side Hustle
should I start
generate
around thousand dollars generate
thousand dollars
income that would be per day
and that would be with minimum
investment amount
right and this is
okay with minimum investment
and I can also tell him how many hours I
can dedicate so I can dedicate it
to 10 hours
okay uh you know it took 10 hours
to this side as well
press enter
so you could see that chat Jeopardy
replies us that as a computer science
engineer with expense and sales and
marketing there's several side of Health
two generate thousand dollars income per
day
and he has stated the first one is
e-commerce then affiliate marketing
digital products you can create and sell
digital products such as ebooks okay
freelancing social media management and
YouTube channel you can start your
YouTube channel
so these are the ideas that you can get
from chatgpt and but these ideas
tailored to user skills and interests
that I have put in now it's time to take
these ideas and discuss them further
with chat Jeopardy to conceptualize a
plan so consider important factors like
alternatively you can begin by stating
generate a new business idea or digital
products you can write that and he will
guide you how you can start it or you
could just write
can you elaborate
the business
idea
of
digital
products
I am on
to start the side
hustle with this
and then you press enter and you can see
that it has started
the process for the business idea
certainly starting a side hustle
centered around digital products can be
located when fulfing Venture identify
your expertise
at manure areas of knowledge skills and
passion and then he has stated choose
your product format create valuable
content set up an online platform Market
your products build an audience optimize
for conversions provide excellent
customer support so these are the parts
he has stated and moreover you can
elaborate those parts also you can just
ask chat Deputy so how can I identify my
expertise and he will guide you with
that so you can go deep down and explore
any business idea so this was the first
method through which you can generate
income from chat upd and moving on the
next would be freelancing so take your
freelancing game to the next level with
chair Jeopardy this date of the art AI
tool is enabling professionals to earn
extra income and produce top quality
content that pose clients companies are
even offering incentives for those who
utilize this technology to create
polished well researched work so here
are some freelance services that you can
offer using chat GPT
starting with you can write blog or
website content using chatgpt for others
you can translate any language with chat
jpt you can craft compelling headlines
and calls to action with chat GPT and
moreover you can do create social media
content for posts or marketing for other
people or any advertising agency you can
write captivating short stories using
chat deputy and you can conduct hashtag
research using chatributing that is you
can find what is trending and offer your
services to other people and gain money
so these are the ways in which you could
freelance and have some money in your
pockets you could just write a command
that would be write a blog post
and
you could write on any topic that would
be write a blog post on
U.S economy
so you could use this AI tool as your
means like what the
what your client required you can use
for that and write the perfect without
plagiarism content that would be blog
post and you can translate any language
with chat repeat you can write
competitive headlines and calls and you
can also write social media content that
would be you can use SEO research for
that and you can write short stories
also see that he has given you the blog
post on the topic U.S economy the
navigating uh the title is navigating
the current state of the U.S economic
Trends and insights and you can see that
it has given you six points and if you
want more you can just ask him to
elaborate
elaborate this
and I've won this blog post
in 800 words
so the thing you just have to do is
write the script write the prompt you
have to just prompt scripting and that
too in the easy language that is in
English and you will get all your
answers from the chat GPD
so now it will write the blog post that
will be in 800 words
so
it's good and moving on
what we'll do let's check out one of
five Learners what he has to say about
our courses we need to keep updating
your skills on a regular basis no matter
what level you're at I recently
completed the professional certificate
program in Ai and machine learning from
Simply learn in partnership with Purdue
University the course material was
comprehensive and the faculty was
extremely experienced The Faculty was
able to adjust their teaching style in
order to cater to the overall skill set
of the class in the rapidly evolving
world of technology it's important to
keep up Skilling for every working
professional stay relevant continue
learning now coming back so the third
passive income you could make using
charge up it is building a software
imagine this scenario you have an issue
with your online business
and you realize that many other people
are facing the same problem well here's
where chair deputy comes to the rescue
you can utilize chair Jeopardy to create
software using the code provided by the
AI and then you can sell these software
tools to make money it's as simple as
that by leveraging chat Jeopardy's
powerful capabilities you can develop
innovative solutions to common problems
and turn them into valuable software
tools whether it's automating a task
streamlining a process or providing a
unique service the possibilities are
endless once you have created your
software tools you can Market them to
your target audience researching out to
those who can benefit from your solution
and guess what people are always looking
for convenient and efficient software
tools to enhance their business so
there's a ready Market waiting for you
so selling software tools not only
allows you to earn a steady income but
also impose others to overcome
challenges and improve their own
Ventures it's a win-win situation so if
you are a problem solver and have a
knack of four coding why not use charge
ability to create software tools that
can make a real happy start by
identifying common pain points that also
you can ask from chat Jeopardy you can
just ask the chat jpt I want to create a
software to help others during or in
online processes in online e-commerce so
he'll give you suggestions and then you
can proceed with those suggestions and
create a software and then you can sell
it or you can use for your own use
so now embrace the power chat GPT tap
into its coding expertise and unlock the
potential to create and sell software
tools so your journey to financial
success starts right here and moving on
we'll move to the next income source
that we can gain from chat jbd so you
can boost your affiliate marketing with
chat Jeopardy's email expertise so do
you know that chat Deputy processes
exceptional writing skills it's true
this incredible chatbot can drop
convincing emails that motivate users to
take action whether it's clicking on
affiliate links making purchases or
subscribing to Services charitivity has
caught you power that's impressive
ability to generate engaging content you
can Captivate your audience and compel
them to take the desired actions so
we'll get back to the chat GPT and ask
him that
I am an email marketer
and you need to
sell my CRM software
so right
an email
only
so I can attract
customer
and make them bite
okay
now you could see that it is writing
email for you and you can launch your
email affiliate marketing campaign also
now that we understand the power of chat
shipping let's discuss how you can
Kickstart our email affiliate marketing
campaign the first step is to choose an
affiliate program that aligns with your
Niche whether it's Amazon's Spotify
Shopify convertkit or any other program
make sure it suits your target audience
next it's time to build an email list of
potential customers who are generally
interested in your promoted products or
Services you can use lead magnets or
employ other effective methods to
encourage email signups you could see
that he has written the email that is I
hope this email finds you well as an
email marketed person okay this is for
me and you could start from here at your
company we have developed a powerful CRM
solution tailored specifically for email
marketers like yourself our software
combines Advanced features username okay
here is written for uh email marketers
only as targeted audience that is email
marketer no issue you can ask him to
change that and like you can craft
compelling emails with chair Jeopardy
and this is where chat triple truly
shines with its assistance you can
create highly engaging emails that not
only inform users about the benefits of
the products but also Inspire them to
click on your affiliate links and make
purchases imagine having a chat about by
your side imagine having a chatbot by
your side helping you write captivating
emails effortlessly by incorporating
persuasive language compelling
storytelling and personalized touch your
emails will stand out in crowded inboxes
and generate higher click-through rates
so this is how chat Jeopardy can help
you in email marketing now the next
method is leverage child Jeopardy for
blogging success in the realm of
blogging chair Jeopardy offers an area
of advantages that can elevate your
content creation Journey so the first is
content generation so Unleash the Power
of this AI driven tool to spank your
creativity and overcome brightness block
chat GPT assist bloggers by generating
ideas crafting outlines anyone providing
complete routes for blog posts say
goodbye to our spend on research the
charge Deputy you can access relevant
information statistics and facts and
mere seconds elevate your blogging game
and Unleash Your Potential with this
invaluable source
and then you can add it and proof it
using charge everyday if you have
written any content and get any content
written you could just write what we
have already written that was write a
blog post on U.S economy that we have
seen in freelancing uh side Hustle but
here you can write and not only write
but also if you have added some points
with your research you can proofread and
edit by using charge APD that is for
bloggery proves to be a valuable asset
by offering assistance in editing
proofreading and enhancing the overall
readability of your blog post it
provides suggestions and Corrections for
spelling grammar and comprehension
reducing errors and ensuring Clarity let
chat Jeopardy Define your writing and
ensure a blog post shine with
professionalism the next what you can do
for a blogging journey is keyword
research and SEO optimization so this is
a fundamental aspect of successful
blogging chargipti becomes your trusted
companion in optimizing a blog post for
search engines it suggests relevant
keywords to include guides you on a
structure in your content for maximum
visibility and offer steps to enhance
your online presence maximize your blogs
reach and attract more organic traffic
in chat JPS SEO expertise and then we
have audience engagement and I will also
show you how we can relate keywords so
for SEO you could just search that would
be gaming related
SEO keywords
for and the topic could be online
shopping
and press enter so here are some related
SEO keywords for online shopping you
could see all these you could mention
these on your backlinks if you have
website or you could add into your blog
posts hashtags which can gain you rank
when searched so moving back the next
was audience engagement so engaging your
audience is key to building a thriving
blow charity can assist you in
connecting with the readers on a deeper
level it provides conversation starters
answer common questions and addresses
concerns from your Audience by
leveraging Charity's capabilities you
can post on meaningful interactions
cultivate a lower following and force
lasting connections with your readers by
harnessing the power of charge upity
Brokers can consistently produce high
quality content Captivate their target
audience bolster their online presence
and generate passive income embrace the
potential of charge deputy and embark on
an exciting blog journey to relieve a
lasting impact so moving on we'll now
see another side herself that is unlock
the potential of shared Jeopardy for
affiliate marketing and you could do
easily affiliate marketing if you have
this vlogging thing
so affiliate marketing opens up a world
of earning possibilities and chat
Jeopardy can be your trusted Ally on
this rewarding Journey users of charge
Deputy can leverage its capabilities to
generate income through affiliate
marketing this powerful tool provides a
seamless value for promoting Goods
services and Brands all while learning a
commission based on resulting sales
embarking on an affiliate marketing
Venture requires thoughtful planning as
a blogger or content creator you must
carefully select the medium through
which you will build your audience
whether it's through captivating
articles engaging audio content or
compelling videos you have the freedom
to choose the format that aligns with
your strengths and resonates with your
target audience when you have
established your audience building
medium chair Deputy steps into support
your affiliate marketing efforts this AI
driven tool empowers you to craft
persuasive content that effectively
promotes the products or Services you
are affiliated with while collaborating
with chair Jeopardy you can tap into its
exceptional writing skills and create
captivating promotional materials that
resonate with video audience as you
implement your affiliate marketing
strategy chargibility becomes an
invaluable resource it helps you draft
engaging articles record compelling
audio content or script captivating
videos that highlight the benefits and
value of the products or services that
you are promoting so remember affiliate
marketing is a process that requires
dedication and perseverance through
consistent effort and support of Charity
you can unlock the potential of earning
substantial income by promoting products
and services that resonate with your
audience and this was for the affiliate
marketing and the next big thing is
utilize chair Jeopardy for ebook writing
and self-publishing so are you a
passionate writer seeking fresh and
innovative ideas look no further
revolutionizes your writing experience
in a recent report that revealed that AI
written ebooks have experienced a
remarkable search on Amazon so you could
just go and charge deputy and ask him
I want to write a self
help book
add to
Black version free
okay I think yeah no spelling is correct
and it should have
resonating
chapters there's no needing
chapters
so
provide me
with a list of chapters
as you can see that
it will Define you and you can also ask
the title for the book and it will give
you the perfect title and you can see
the chapter that is introducing setting
the stage for personal growth
discovering your authentic self
cultivating a positive mindset and after
that you can ask chat Deputy to
elaborate these topics that would be in
some words in some pages and you can use
the same content to write a book and you
can also ask the title from the chat jpd
as you create a companion the
possibilities are boundless you don't
need to possess the skills of literary
genius to make an impact in the e-book
Market Kindle Direct publishing offers
seamless platform to Showcase your book
and make it easily accessible to
enthusiastic readers while leveraging
child Deputy to assist in writing your
ebook you will save precious time and
energy allowing you to concentrate on
marketing and promoting your work
effectively so this is how you can write
ebooks and generate income
using chair GPD moving on we have next
passive income that is utilized chat
Jeopardy to enhance your YouTube channel
so chargeable is an invaluable tool that
can assist you in generating captivating
video ideas you can ask him the video
ideas also and this is the creative
block which activity can even cool the
extra mile by creating a script for
YouTube videos
so let's tap into the creative pros and
we'll ask chair jpt I want to create a
YouTube video
on topic
uh GDP
that is close domestic product and
I need your help
writing the script for that
so you could see that chair jpd has
started its work so it's showing welcome
back to our channel in today's video
we'll be diving into the fascinating
world of Cubit GDP what exactly is GDP
and why is it such an important measure
of our country's economy so you can see
that it has created the script for your
YouTube video and it is also telling you
the scenes
so this is how you could leverage your
Japanese capabilities and that can give
you YouTube channel a significant boost
helping you create engaging content and
capture the attention of your audience
so start exploring the possibilities
with Charity today and witness your
channel Thrive so moving on the next we
have is writing lyrics for music so when
it comes to music the words we use in
songs are super important they have the
power to make us feel all kinds of
emotions and connect with people and now
there's a cool tool called chargabity
that can help you write awesome song
lyrics with Chad Jeopardy you can take
your ideas and turn them into beautiful
words that touch people's heart it's
like having a virtual writing buddy that
help you come up with catchy lines and
cool Rhymes you can play around with
different ways to express yourself and
make your lyrics stand out so you can
chat GPT to write lyrics for you here we
wrap up AIML chat jpt course if you like
this video share it with your friends if
you have any questions feel free to add
it in the comment section below stay
tuned with latest updates on technology
by subscribing to Simply learn Channel
thanks for watching
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign